Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder.
Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder.
Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Und wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder. Mit im Studio der Frank, Harald, Tim und meine Person, der Max. Thema heute Abend Firewalls und Co. Und bevor wir jetzt richtig loslegen und auf die ganz speziellen Fragen eingehen, wollen wir natürlich erstmal klären, bevor wir zu der Frage kommen, was sind Firewalls, wie das Internet überhaupt funktioniert. Tim, was ist denn da? Du hast was am Hals.
Du musst die Musik laufen lassen. Wir müssen noch was klären.
Ja, warte mal Hasi, ich komm mal zu dir rüber. Könnte Tim vielleicht mal eben kurz eine Anekdote aus seinem Leben erzählen, während ich da rumgehe?
Lass einfach mal die Musik laufen.
Wir spielen wieder nur Musik, ich dachte wir reden hier über Technisches. Ihr hört die best vorbereitetste Sendung im deutschen Radio, deswegen auch Chaosradio genannt. Die anwesenden Sissis und Pussis sind Frank, Harald, Tim und Max. So Jungs, dürft ich euch bitten, ins kleine lustige Thema einzuleiten, um das wir uns heute Abend kümmern.
Gerne. Wir wollen uns heute um die spezielle Problematik kümmern, die in der Regel entsteht, wenn man zu Hause oder auch im Büro an das Internet zugreifen möchte.
Oder auch im Fritz-Studio.
Oder auch im Fritz-Studio. Da hatten wir heute auch schon eine längere Diskussion drüber. Und einen besonderen Schwerpunkt auf populäre Technologien legen, die da heißen NAT und Firewalls. Und auch noch ein paar andere Sachen, die damit in Zusammenhang hängen. DHCP, also sprich alle Protokolle und Wesensarten des Internets, die einen konkret zu Hause beim Betrieb des eigenen Rechners oder der eigenen Rechner am Internet betreffen.
Jetzt hatten wir uns natürlich auch vorbereitend darüber unterhalten. Wie gehen wir da ran? Und fangen wir direkt an zu erklären, was eine Firewall ist. Und dann haben wir uns dazu entschlossen, erst mal klarzumachen, wie das Internet überhaupt funktioniert, weil damit hängt im Endeffekt alles zusammen. Und ich erkläre das jetzt nicht.
Okay, dann werde ich mich wohl dran machen an dieses Thema. Ja, wie funktioniert das Internet? Im Grunde geht es alles um schöne kleine Päckchen, die aber nicht irgendwie vom Postboten an die Tür gebracht werden, sondern eben um Datenpakete. Und diese Datenpakete werden von Rechnern in diesem Netzwerk hin und her geschickt. Und damit so ein Paket ähnlich wie ein Postpaket ankommen kann, gibt es Adressen. Es gibt eine Absenderadresse, es gibt eine Empfängeradresse. Und dann gibt es zwischendurch dieses ominöse schwarze Netzwerk, das diese Pakete vom Absender zum Empfänger durchstellt. Und die einzelnen Punkte im Netzwerk, an denen entschieden wird, wo dieses Paket, wo welche Abzweigungen nimmt in diesem Netzwerk, die werden im Router genannt. Und damit haben wir auch schon den ersten Begriff irgendwo definiert. Der Router ist also ein Knotenpunkt im Netzwerk, der Pakete von links nach rechts weiterreicht. So, wenn ich jetzt zu Hause oder an einem beliebigen Rechner eben anfange mit dem Netzwerk zu kommunizieren, dann werden da Datenpakete losgeschickt über mehrere solche Router hintereinander im Netzwerk durch die Gegend geschickt und kommen dann irgendwann letztendlich bei dem Rechner an, den ich ansprechen will und der antwortet und schickt mir ein Antwortpaket, schreibt eben als Empfängeradresse die Adresse drauf, die ich vorher als Absender dieses Anfragepaket angeschrieben hatte und schickt diese diese Antwort zurück an den eigentlichen Absender des Anfragepakets. Das ist so im Wesentlichen, wie das Netzwerk funktioniert.
Genau, dann gibt es noch ein paar Begriffe, die man halt häufig hört und die nicht selten ein bisschen aus dem Zusammenhang gerissen sind und die es wert sind, mal etwas besser verstanden zu werden. Einen voran natürlich IP. Techniker nehmen das halt gerne mal auch so locker in den Mund und sprechen einfach nur von IP, während man ja generell eigentlich immer von TCP-IP redet. IP ist das eigentliche Internetprotokoll, daher auch die Abkürzung IP Internetprotokoll. Und das sind also IP-Pakete, sind die Pakete, die sich im Internet von Computer zu Computer bewegen und sind auch quasi die einzigen Pakete, die sich da bewegen. Wenn man dann ein Paket empfangen hat, dann muss das natürlich dann auch an das richtige Programm zugestellt werden, weil natürlich mehrere Programme gleichzeitig irgendetwas tun. Der Webbrowser holt sich eine Seite von einem Web-Server, das Chatprogramm redet halt mit dem Chat-Server und so weiter. Und damit man das eben noch unterscheiden kann, gibt es eine sogenannte Portnummer. Das muss man sich vorstellen, wie die IP-Adresse so deine Straße und Hausnummer ist, dann ist die Portnummer sozusagen das passende Klingelschild dazu, damit der Computer weiß, an wen in dem Haus das jetzt weiter gereicht werden soll. Diese Portnummer spielen eine große Rolle in dem ganzen Spiel, was wir jetzt hier beschreiben wollen. Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass man das eben auseinanderhält. Also Portnummer ist sozusagen die Unterscheidung der Zustellung auf deinem Computer und die IP-Adresse ist dein Computer.
Man muss jetzt auch dazu sagen, dass in dem Haus nicht nur vier Parteien wohnen, sondern auf so einem Computer, wenn man es auf Portnummern hochrechnet, wie viele ungefähr?
Gängigerweise 2 mal 65.635.
Also es handelt sich um ein Hochhaus?
Das heißt also jede Verbindung zeichnet sich eigentlich durch vier Parameter aus. Das sind irgendwie die Absenderadresse, die Zieladresse, Absender Port und Ziel Port.
So, und jetzt wo wir das geklärt haben, kommt natürlich die Frage ins Spiel, wo ist da die Firewall angesiedelt, über die wir uns unterhalten, beziehungsweise NAT?
Ja, im Grunde habe ich ja vorhin von sogenannten Routern gesprochen, also solche Vermittlungsknotenpunkte im Netz. Und jetzt an so einem Punkt, wo Pakete weiter zugestellt werden, da kann ich natürlich mir so ein Paket angucken und kann entscheiden, was mache ich mit dem Paket? Gefällt mir das Paket? Ist der Inhalt das, was ich haben will? Oder gibt es den Empfänger überhaupt, was auch immer? Und dann kann ich eben selektiv auf einem solchen Router, kann ich selektiv sagen, dieses Paket kommt durch, das andere Paket kommt nicht durch. Und dann habe ich eigentlich schon an dieser Stelle eine Firewall und ganz spezifisch, wenn man es genau bezeichnen will, einen sogenannten Paketfilter, der sich eben beim Weiterleiten der Pakete überlegt, welches Paket ist zulässig und welches Paket ist nicht zulässig und daraufhin dann eben ein Paket verwirft oder weiterleitet. Also können wir festhalten, ein Paketfilter ist eine mögliche Firewall. Es gibt unterschiedliche Technologien, mit denen man Firewalls bauen kann. Ein Paketfilter ist eine davon und ein Paketfilter ist ein selektiver Router.
Von außen betrachtet ist das Ganze im Prinzip eine Box, wo zwei Netzwerkanschlüsse sind, einer rein, einer raus. Und die Box entscheidet, welche von den Paketen, die auf dem Eingangsinterface kommen, auch an das Zweite weitergereicht werden und umgekehrt.
Wenn ich jetzt ein ganz normaler Windows-User bin, wozu brauche ich sowas?
Na ja, damals, als das Internet ja noch ein friedliches Dorf war, das jungfräuliche Internet, wo nur wohlmeinde Wissenschaftler zum gegenseitigen Nutzen Daten ausgetauscht haben, war das halt alles überhaupt gar kein Thema. Da hat man sich eigentlich um solche Sachen auch noch keine Gedanken gemacht. Und im Prinzip bräuchte man eigentlich keine Firewall, gäbe es halt nicht Leute, die das Netz eben auch noch zu anderen Sachen benutzen. Wir wissen ja alle, es gibt da verschiedene Problematiken im Netz, seien es Viren, seien es sogenannte DOS-Attacken, Denial-of-Service-Attacken, also Angriffe auf den eigenen Computer, die verhindern sollen, dass man noch in der Lage ist, bestimmte Dienste anzubieten oder eben auch einfach der Zugriff auf die eigenen Daten. Man hat ja nicht unbedingt seinen Computer immer so sicher konfiguriert, dass man sich auch sicher sein kann, dass er nicht irgendwelche Daten rausgibt, die man gar nicht rausgeben möchte. Das ist das Problem dieser Dateifreigabe zum Beispiel. Sodass es gar keine schlechte Idee ist, grundsätzlich seine Computer ein wenig oder eben auch ein wenig mehr von dem Netz abzuschotten und das eben durch dieses Brandmauer-Modell, also diese Firewall, die erstmal dazwischen steht und die erstmal sagt, naja, bestimmte Dinge lasse ich durch, bestimmte Dinge lasse ich nicht durch, weil dadurch kann ich schon mal Sachen von mir fernhalten, ohne dass mein Computer dafür gerüstet sein muss.
Wobei sich in der Praxis unterscheidet in, oder nicht wirklich unterscheidet, aber wir kennen diese Firewalls als sogenannte Personal Firewalls. Das ist das, was wir auf einem Rechner als Software installieren, also auf unserem Arbeitsplatz-PC oder auf unserem Laptop, was also als ein Stück Software da läuft und es gibt welche, die zum Beispiel in Form von einem DSL-Router oder einem Gerät, was jetzt bei einem Firmennetzwerk eingebaut ist, was halt ein extra eigenständiges Gerät ist, was dann auch ein ganzes Netzwerk abschotten soll.
Gut, heute Abend wollen wir natürlich über eure Erfahrungen damit reden, also das heißt zum einen über Erfahrungen, die ihr selber mit so Personal Firewalls gemacht habt oder auch mit etwas spezifischeren, die dann so in so großen Geräten sind, wenn ihr vielleicht euch doch damit auskennt. Interessant geworden ist das Ganze ja eigentlich dadurch, dass diese neuartigen Viren, wie es sie jetzt seit einiger Zeit gibt, also Sasa wird euch wahrscheinlich noch im Gedächtnis sein, dass solche kleinen Viecher sich unabhängig davon, ob ihr jetzt eine Webseite besucht oder unabhängig davon, ob ihr vielleicht den Anhang einer Mail geöffnet habt, einfach so weiterverbreiten, indem sie nach offenen Ports scannen, das was wir erzählt haben. Also die gucken einfach, ist bei dem Klingelschild jemand zu Hause und lässt er mich möglicherweise rein? Und man braucht im Grunde gar nicht eine große Aktion selber durchzuführen, die finden einen von selbst. Und dagegen helfen solche Firewalls halt extrem gut. Vielleicht habt ihr ja auch schon mal versucht, euch so ein Ding einzurichten und habt Fragen dazu, dann könnt ihr auf jeden Fall anrufen unter 033 77 97 1 1 0. So, sind wir soweit fertig mit den Basics oder?
Ja, also zu dem Aufruf. Also uns würde vor allem auch interessieren, wenn ihr jetzt ganz spezielle eigene Firewall Installation zu Hause bastelt mit einer bestimmten Intention, das würde uns natürlich besonders interessieren.
Was heißt eine bestimmte Intention?
Ja, dass man also nicht einfach, also es gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten, die schon angedeutet sind. Entweder man nimmt halt so ein Gerät, was das tut, oder man installiert so eine Personal Firewall, was sich irgendwie konfigurieren lässt. Aber es gibt eben auch Leute, die setzen sich ihren eigenen Computer auf, der ausschließlich diese Firewall-Tätigkeit nimmt.
Wir wollen natürlich auch von euch wissen, benutzt ihr diese Dinger, benutzt ihr Personal Firewalls, habt ihr die auf dem Computer? Wenn ja, warum? Wenn nein, warum nicht? Ja, stellt uns Fragen.
Genau, 0317097110 und der Sven aus Potsdam ist auch schon am Telefon. Hallo Sven.
Hallo und?
Dann leg doch mal los. Hast du ein Problem mit deiner Firewall?
Ich hatte mir erst 32 Blaster eingefangen. Hab zwar froh, dass ich ihn runtergekriegt hab, bin das nächste Mal ins Interesse gegangen, hat mir Sasser eingefangen. Den Fond, dass ich ihn runterbekommen hab.
Sag mal, rauscht da denn ein Rechner im Hintergrund ganz laut oder so?
Ja, macht er. Jo und dann hab ich jetzt endlich mal eine einständige Firewall gefunden, weil ich hatte vorher Norton, Andy Joostorf, der hat ja auch gleich ne Firewall damit drin, aber die hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert und jetzt hab ich Cario, falls ich das fast sag.
Die hab ich auch mal gehabt.
Die ist eigentlich ganz lustig, die funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut, weil Zone-Alarm hatte ich bloß die englische Version da und auf Englisch ist die relativ schwer zu konfigurieren.
Kannst du noch mal genau sagen, wie die heißt, weil wir schütteln gerade alle mit ein bisschen... Also Cario mit K oder was ist das?
Das sind tatsächlich so die gängigsten, also ich kenne auch jemanden in der Redaktion, der Zone-Alarm draufgepackt hat und Cario hatte ich selber mal, das sind so die, die man auch empfohlen bekommt, wenn man bei Heise mal guckt, was die so Freeware-mäßig, ganz oben Sterne-mäßig sagen, das finden viele User gut, da sind die auch dabei.
Das Schöne ist, der hat auch gleich ein Pop-up-Locker mit drin.
Für Webseiten, das ist so, für Webseiten meinst du?
Ja, ja, also dass ich nicht für die ganzen Userebe...
Und Cario hat auch direkt Cookie-Washer und sowas, ne?
Das heißt, er macht also nicht nur, ist praktisch nicht nur ein Paket-Fehler, sondern guckt sich auch wirklich dann auf Anwendungsebene die Sachen an. Also wir haben, er ist schon...
Er fragt mich momentan bei jeder Sache, die ich ausführe, ob er das wirklich immer lassen soll. Egal, ob ich jetzt, was weiß ich, wenn ich Nero starte, dass der ein anderes Programm öffnet, dann kommt die Warnung, Programm öffnet, anderes Programm soll zugelassen werden. Aber okay, muss ich halt einfach noch mal leben.
Würdest du da nicht irgendwann müde, dann also immer dieses okay, also das typische Phänomen auch beim Internet Explorer oder allgemein beim Webklicken, dass die Leute geneigt sind, einfach alle Fenster irgendwie ja, okay, wegdrücken einfach, ohne dann irgendwann dann so ein Abstumpfungseffekt eintritt.
Bei den gängigen Fenstern, die ich kenne, mache ich das inzwischen auch. Aber wenn ich da, also ich überfliege mal den Text und wenn ich da sehe, oh, da ist was Neues, dann lese ich mir das mal richtig durch.
Verstehst du dann auch, was da steht? Also mal ganz ehrlich?
Ja, also wenn es jetzt zum Beispiel um irgendwelche Zertifikate geht, lese ich mir das voll genauer durch oder so.
Das ist auch gut so. Also ich habe auch viele Leute schon dabei zugeschaut, wie sie so mit ihrer eigenen Personal Firewall rumklicken und die tendieren dann immer dazu, dass sie dann eher von den Fenstern genervt sind und sowieso immer Ja und Amen sagen oder eben auch immer Nein und Amen und sich danach beschweren, dass irgendwas nicht geht. Also wenn man sich sowas schon installiert.
Oder dass dann plötzlich doch wieder die Würmer auf dem Rechner sind.
Man ist dann gut beraten, sich vielleicht das Handbuch auch mal wirklich durchzulesen.
Ein Thema, das mich momentan ein bisschen stört, ich habe dazu als Antivirus-Programm halt Antivirus-6 drauf, falls ich das fast sage. Antivirus ist dieses komische rote Zeichen mit dem Regenschirm. Probiere ich seit Tagen Updates zu machen, klappt irgendwie nicht. Frag mich bitte nicht warum.
Wahrscheinlich bist du nicht der einzige.
Vielleicht bloggst du ja dann im Personal Firewall die Virus Updates.
Und ist das was, was du einem unbedarften User auch so empfehlen könntest?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe das jetzt, wenn ich mal kurz gleich umhänge, von der aktuellen MPC-Praxis gezogen. Da war nämlich das Service Pack 2 für Windows XP drauf. Mit 56k wollte ich mir das nicht saugen, deswegen habe ich das über die Zeitung gemacht.
Du hast ja das Windows Update bei der Zeitung geholt.
Da sind aber so CDs bei, oder?
Ja, genau, da sind auch CDs.
Moment, ganz kurz, Tim, das wirst du nicht kennen. Zeitungen sind so aus Papier, so gefaltete Dinger und dann drucken irgendwelche Freaks da Buchstaben drauf.
Ah, Tote Bäume. Nee, ich dachte nur, du hättest dir jetzt gerade vom Web-Server von denen gezogen. Da hätte ich dann von abgeraten, sich Windows-Updates... Na, warum sollte man sich nicht Windows-Updates von irgendwelchen Servern runterladen, weil man sich nicht sicher sein kann. Ja, und auch PC-Praxis wäre an der Stelle erstmal nur irgendeiner, weil man weiß ja halt nicht... Also man weiß auch bei Microsoft nicht, was da kommt, aber...
Windows-Updates nie bei Microsoft runterladen.
Das Problem zumindest isoliert.
Gab es denn jetzt grundsätzliche Probleme, weil das ist ja jetzt nur das Setting, was wir besprochen haben. Was sind jetzt die Probleme, oder wolltest du einfach nur sagen, dass du das und das hast?
Also einerseits, dass ich das habe und dass ich halt diese Probleme habe, jetzt verkomme ich von Windows, bekomme ich öfters so eine Fehlermeldung, SkyNet, vom SkyNet Team steht, würde das mal unterschrieben, auch im Offline-Modus, dass ich irgendeinen Warm Blaster drauf habe und dass ich mir den BPD installieren sollte. Ich habe das Antilim-Programm rüber laufen lassen, ich habe nochmal den Microsoft Patch drauf, und der bringt das immer noch.
Ich frag mich, was das ist.
Wer bringt das, deine Firewall oder dein SkyNet?
Das heißt, es ist einfach nur ein Pop-up von einem Programm, wo du nicht weißt, wo es herkommt, und da sagt dir jetzt irgendwas drauf.
Das ist ein Microsoft Pop-up.
Na ja, das weiß man ja nicht.
Das gibt es ja durchaus nicht aus, sage ich mal so. Deine Probleme mit dem Anti-VIA, erfahre ich gerade aus dem Chat, könnten damit zu tun haben, dass du die nicht-kommerzielle Version verwendest, ist das richtig? Weil da sind die Update-Server schlicht überlastet. Wenn du die kommerzielle Version hast, dann haben sie die Server auf einem anderen Rechner, der nicht so überlastet ist, und da scheint es die Probleme nicht zu geben.
Jo, also was das Programm da anbelangt mit dem Pop-up, da hast du wahrscheinlich irgendeinen anderen Virus, der dich verarscht, bevor er dich dann killt, oder irgendwie sowas Schönes. Also zieh dir einfach mal das Update von Anti-VIA. Dummerwitz, ich weiß. Aber einfach ein Momentchen warten vielleicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn ich warte, dann steht da, wird beendet, Server geht aus oder so, Server runtergefahren, kommt dann von, kommt dann die Fehlermeldung.
Geduld und Spucke, Sven. Danke für den Anruf. So, jetzt kommen natürlich direkt Fragen, weil wir ja doch viele Begriffe in den Raum geworfen haben. Unter anderem ist am Telefon der Lars. Hallo, Lars. Mit einer Frage.
Ja, und zwar würde ich ganz gern mal wissen, ob ein Router die gleiche Firewall-Funktionalität hat. Also, ich hab praktisch ein Intranet, ein kleines Intranet, was ich dauerhaft praktisch mit Zugang zum Internet versehen möchte. Und da steht jetzt praktisch ein Router dran. Und so ein Router macht es ja möglich, dass man praktisch also das private Netz nach außen eigentlich erstmal nicht sichtbar macht. Ja, ist jetzt die Frage, reicht dieser Router da oder muss ich da noch eine Firewall dazusetzen?
Also wir müssen generell mal noch trennen zwischen den Begriffen Routern, Firewall und NAT. Und was so diese typische DSL Anwendung ist, dass du eine NAT hast und wo auch natürlich ein Router drin ist. Also da ist das so ein bisschen verknüpft.
Können wir das kurz nochmal erklären?
Das haben wir ja noch gar nicht erläutert. Grundsätzlich erstmal Router heißt nichts anderes, dass er die Pakete weiterreicht, sonst nüscht. Das ist eine Funktionalität, die du brauchst, weil sonst kommt keine Pakete an. Eine Firewall brauchst du dann, wenn du etwas blockieren möchtest. NAT brauchst du dann, wenn du mehr als einen Computer betreiben möchtest. Ein Abfallprodukt von diesem NAT ist, dass es schon so ein bisschen sich auch wie eine Firewall verhält, weil da geht nicht alles so ohne weiteres durch, sondern es gehen eigentlich nur Antworten auf das, was du rausgeschickt hast, gehen halt wieder zurück.
Also mal ganz kurz, NAT steht für Network Address Translation. Das heißt also, deine Adressen von deinem internen Netz werden auf dem Router, auf diesem NAT Gateway übersetzt in eine externe Adresse. Und dabei merkt sich aber bei jeder Verbindung, die von innen nach draußen geht, merkt sich dieser Router, welche Verbindung er nach außen weiter gereicht hat. Das werden die Daten zurückkommen, die er mit seiner Tabelle, die er sich da angelegt hat, die Verbindung, die er sich gemerkt hat, dann wieder zurück zuordnen zu den Rechnern im internen Netz.
Okay, also durch diese Adress-Translation ist es doch, sehe ich das richtig, ist es so gewährleistet, dass eigentlich ein Rechner, der mich von außen jetzt versucht, anzupingen, also unter meiner Intranet-IP-Adresse, dass er mich eigentlich nicht sieht, sondern der sieht eigentlich wirklich von außen nur diesen Router oder diesen NAT.
Der kann gar keine Adresse von drinnen anpingen, weil die gibt es ja draußen gar nicht. Können wir dazu kurz auf was sagen, was diese internen Adressen sind?
Es gibt IP-Adressen, die speziell für private Zwecke gedacht sind. Es gibt IP-Adressen, die weltweit im Internet eindeutig sind und die geroutet werden, sogenannte offizielle IP-Adressen und eben auch Adressen, die man im privaten Bereich verwenden kann. Am bekanntesten ist davon der 192.168.x.x-Bereich, der freigehalten wird für private Netze. Da kann ich jetzt mein Netzwerk daheim aufziehen, kann mir da 65.000 Rechner reinstellen mit diesen privaten Adressen, die zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Dein Nachbar verwende dann eben genau die gleichen Adressen. Diese Adressen sind natürlich nicht eindeutig, sondern wenn du mit deinem Nachbarn kommunizieren möchtest, dann müssen das eindeutige Adressen sein. Das geschieht über diese sogenannten offiziellen IP-Adressen, die du von deinem Provider bekommst und die der Nachbar von deinem Provider bekommt. Da bekommt ihr aber in aller Regel bei den End-User-Internetzugängen immer nur eine davon. Deswegen ist es eben üblich, dass man da ein sogenanntes NAT-Gerät eben hinstellt, das diese Übersetzung macht von den vielen internen Adressen auf die eine offizielle äußere Adresse.
Also sollte jetzt praktisch nach so einem NAT eigentlich nochmal eine Firewall stehen, die jetzt bestimmte Pakete dann so rausfiltert?
Das kann schon alles in einem Gerät sein. Das kommt halt ganz genau darauf an, was für ein Produkt du kaufst. Es gibt reine Router, es gibt reine, also es gibt erstmal reine Router. Dann gibt es Router, die zusätzlich noch einen Paketfilter haben, die also eine Firewall darstellen. Dann gibt es Router, die Router und NAT machen. Und es gibt Geräte, die Router, NAT und Firewall machen. Und dann vielleicht sogar noch mehr. Vielleicht zum Beispiel noch ein Wireless LAN Access Point sind oder was auch immer. Also es gibt da die unterschiedlichsten Kombinationen. Und dummerweise wird von den Marketingabteilungen der Firmen die Terminologie nicht so genau verstanden und auch nicht eingehalten.
Also es läuft absichtlich vermischt.
Es läuft eigentlich vieles unter Router. Das wird halt immer als Router verkauft. Du musst halt genau gucken, was wirklich drin ist.
Genau, richtig. Da musst du ganz genau gucken, was drin ist. Und es gibt eigentlich von den ganzen gängigen Herstellern in jede Kategorie Gerät. Es gibt mindestens ein Produkt. Und die Produkte erneuern sich auch alle drei bis spätestens sechs Monate. Also das ist in der Art unübersichtlicher Markt. Man muss wirklich gucken, was das im Einzelnen macht.
Ja, bitteschön. So, und wenn ihr ähnliche Probleme habt, könnt ihr natürlich auch heute Abend weiter mit reinhören, weil ich glaube, da noch ganz viele Fragen angesprochen werden. Weil wenn man sich erstmal so einen Router gekauft hat, kommen da noch ganz viele Fragen nach, von denen ihr vielleicht momentan noch überhaupt gar keine Ahnung haben könntet. So, wir machen jetzt gleich erstmal ein Häppchen Nachrichten. Lass mich eben kurz orientieren, so, genau.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt oder?
Dann 101, 5.
Dann ist es 20.30 Uhr. Mit dem Wetter, die Nacht ist bewölkt, es kann vereinzelt Schauer geben, die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 3 Grad. Morgen ist es meist stark bewölkt und es soll ebenfalls Schauer geben, vereinzelt sogar Gewitter, also Kackwetter. Die Temperaturen erreichen 13 bis 15 Grad.
Die USA fahnden nach sieben verdächtigen Al-Qaeda-Mitgliedern. Sie sollen einen Anschlag in den Vereinigten Staaten planen. Das gab US-Justizminister Ashcroft bekannt. Demnach stellen die sieben Verdächtigen eine klare aktuelle Gefahr für die USA dar. Die Stadt Köln hat Haftbefehl gegen den Islamisten Metin Kaplan erlassen. Das Ausländeramt wolle sich so die mögliche Abschiebung sichern. Zuvor hatte das Oberverwaltungsgericht in Münster entschieden, dass der als Caliph von Köln bekannt gewordene Kaplan in die Türkei abgeschoben werden kann. Verteidigungsminister Struck lässt Berichte über angebliche Folterungen im Kosovo prüfen. Nach Angaben der Bildzeitung sollen bei der KFOR-Truppe Fotos kursieren, die Folterszenen deutscher Soldaten zeigen. Das Verteidigungsministerium hat diese Gerüchte als haltlos bezeichnet. Bei den schweren Überschwemmungen in Haiti und der Dominikanischen Republik sind mehr als 630 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Allein in Haiti starben nach offiziellen Angaben mindestens 375 Menschen. Die UNO und mehrere Hilfsorganisationen wollten noch heute Helfer nach Haiti senden. Und zum Verkehr? In Berlin-Neukölln gibt es auf der Gutschmiedstraße Fritz-Erler-Allee zwischen der Kreuzung Burkhoa-Damm und der Kreuzung Johannisthaler-Schossee Verkehrsbehinderungen in beiden Richtungen. Grund ist eine geplatzte Wasserleitung. Wir wünschen gute Fahrt.
Fritz und Tipp suchen sie. Die hundert besten Songs der besten Band der Welt. Und ihr bestimmt sie. Rotet jetzt für eure Lieblingssongs der Ärzte. Die 100 besten Songs der besten Band der Welt. Wählt eure Lieblingssongs der Ärzte unter fritz.de. Und im Radio, da ist die Musik.
Den Blue Moon einmal letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Wir haben jetzt eine halbe Stunde schon mal angefangen, ins Thema einzuleiten. Ist für euch alle interessant, ist heute Abend auch gar nicht so freaky, wie man zunächst meinen möchte, weil das sollte euch alle interessieren. Es geht nämlich um Firewalls und Co. Hängen aber viele Begriffe im Raum, die eigentlich erst mal erklärt werden müssen, damit man weiß, warum man das überhaupt braucht. Und deswegen gibt es jetzt noch ein bisschen Terminologiegefussel, und zwar von Frank Haraltim und meiner Person, dem Max.
Okay, ja, was eine Router ist und was IP-Adressen sind, das hatte ich ja schon angesprochen, in den letzten Minuten. Wir haben also den Router als Gerät, das Pakete vermittelt zwischen mehreren Netzwerken. Dann eben den sogenannten Paketfilter, der bei diesem Weiterleiten, bei dem Vermitteln der Pakete noch irgendwie selektiert, welche Pakete irgendwie zulässig sind, welche Pakete nicht zulässig sind. Dann hatten wir das sogenannte NAT, das Network Address Translation. Da gibt es noch eine Abwandlung, das Begriff, die NAPT heißt, also mit PT, ist dann die sogenannte Network Address and Port Translation. Die immer dann notwendig wird, wenn hier zwischen unterschiedlichen Adressräumen übersetzt werden muss. Warum man das tut und wie das mit diesen internen und externen Adressen ist, werde ich gleich noch mal klären. Ich möchte nur noch ein paar andere Begriffe ansprechen, die in dem Dunstkreis gebraucht werden.
Bevor du voll loslegst, weil ich es gerade vergessen habe zu erwähnen, wir haben einerseits gibt es einen IRC-Kanal, den wir hier mitlesen. Für die Leute, die sich noch mit einsteigen wollen, auf irc.freenote.net im Kanal Chaosradio. Und in der Wikipedia, da geht ihr am besten einfach mal auf chaosradio.ccc.de, da ist ein Link auf eine Seite in der Wikipedia. Das ist die Mitmachseite in der Sendung. Wer also noch Anmerkungen hat, Sachen noch mit erklären will, die hier zur Frache gekommen sind, kann dort das Ganze unterbringen.
Wir haben eigentlich auch Mail. Wir haben ja immer eine Mail-Adresse 92 in Chaosradio, wäre es heute. Irgendwie ist da aber etwas komisch mit unserem Mail. Deswegen können wir die auch gerade nicht vorlesen. Wir probieren es mal gerade mit chaosradio.ccc.de, ob das ankommt, hilfsweise. Sagen wir euch gleich nochmal Bescheid.
Dann kann ich mir heute gar keinen Contest mit dir liefern. Das letzte Mal haben wir geeifert. Ich würde dann noch kurz sagen, wenn ihr auf fritz.de geht, haben wir unser Forum geschaltet, habe ich einen kleinen Thread aufgemacht, wenn ihr da was rein texten wollt, könnt ihr euch auch mit anderen Usern dann darüber unterhalten. Also wir haben ganz viele Möglichkeiten. Dann gibt es natürlich noch Telefon. Aber bevor wir wieder mit euch telefonieren, vielleicht noch mal kurz das, was wir noch nicht erklärt haben, war noch irgendwas, was wir vorher klar machen wollten?
Ja, wir hatten den Begriff Firewall, der ja auch irgendwie im Titel steht. Und Firewall ist ein wirklich sehr weitgedehneter Begriff, der irgendwie eine Abschottung, eine Abriegelung zwischen zwei Netzwerkssegmenten meint. Wie das dann technologisch ausgeführt ist, kann ganz unterschiedlich sein. Da gibt es eben sogenannte Paketfelder, die hatte ich ja schon angesprochen. Es gibt aber auch sogenannte Proxies oder auch Application Layer Gateways, die einfach von der technischen Implementation her an einer ganz anderen Stelle eingreifen. Ein Paketfilter filtert eben Netzwerkpakete. Und so Dinge wie Proxies und Application Layer Gateways, die sind, wie wir Techniker sagen, auf einem höheren Layer angesiedelt. Die gucken sich dann tatsächlich den Inhalt zum Beispiel von Webseiten oder von E-Mails an und arbeiten hier technisch auf einer anderen Dimension. Gut, Begriffe?
Also was glaube ich auch nochmal ganz wichtig ist, dass wir darauf hinweisen, ist, wenn man halt, also dieser Bedarf für NAT, der entstand vor allem deshalb, weil wenn man heute beim normalen Internetprovider sich eben Internet holt, dann kriegt man von dem nur eine einzige IP-Adresse zugeteilt. In der Regel. Und zwar in der großen Regel. Das hat verschiedene Gründe. Da gibt es diesen Mythos des auslaufenden Adressraums. Das stimmt nicht wirklich, aber so oder so haben sich irgendwie alle dazu durchgerungen, erstmal sparsam mit diesen Adressen umzugehen, weil sie ja auch der Meinung sind, die Leute brauchen zu Hause sowieso nur eine IP-Adresse. Das ist natürlich eigentlich Quark, weil man hat heutzutage schon auch mal mehr als einen Rechner, den Desktop, den Laptop und was weiß ich, dann kommt mal jemand zu Besuch, sprich den Bedarf mehrere Computer zu betreiben, hat eigentlich schon jeder. Aber die Provider sagen natürlich auch, naja, wenn wir euch jetzt mehrere IP-Adressen geben würden, die auch alle erreichbar sind, dann könntet ihr ja Server zu Hause fahren und dafür wollen wir ja eigentlich viel mehr Geld nehmen, weil das ist ja dann ein Business Service.
Richtig, man betreibt hier also einfach eine Preispolitik, die insbesondere dadurch entstanden ist, dass Internetzugänge heute weniger von ASPs, sondern viel mehr von Telcos, also von Telefonfirmen, angeboten werden, die einfach preislich sehr deutlich schon immer differenzieren zwischen Privatangeboten und zwischen Businessangeboten. Im Grunde ist das ja egal für wen, die diese Pakete weiter reichen, aber wenn man sich die Tarife anguckt, dann wird man sich nur so wundern, wie viel teurer das ist, wenn da auf einmal Business draufsteht. Und man degradiert eben den Standard DSL oder Dial-Up-Zugang eines einzelnen Users sozusagen zu jemandem, der eine Internetverbindung zweiter Klasse bekommt. Und das ist dann eben nur eine einzelne IP-Adresse und die dann auch nur für 12 oder 24 Stunden am Stück. Danach ändert sich die wieder. Gut, unabhängig davon, woher das jetzt kommt oder was der Grund dafür ist, wir müssen uns mit der Situation irgendwie abfinden und damit umgehen. Und genau da ist eben das, wo NAT ins Spiel kommt.
Du hast recht. Wir sind gerade etwas überraten, nachdem ich hier den Kanal angekündigt habe, wir sind jetzt schon bei 88 Teilnehmern im Chat.
Und irgendwie mit der Mail, das funktioniert alles nicht. Und ich kann auch die Fritz Seiten gar nicht lesen. Hier ist irgendwas komisch mit unserem Netz, also irgendwas.
Ja, haben wir denn noch Anrufer?
Na selbstverständlich, ich warte doch nur auf euch. Ich bin froh, dass wir keine Kochsendung machen. Stefan aus Berlin-Mahlstock ist am Telefon. Hallo Stefan. Guten Abend, du hast Fragen.
Also erstmal zur Erklärung, was ich habe. Und zwar habe ich einen Linux-Server im Heimnetzwerk, der die ganzen Firewall-Sachen macht. Und solange ich Linux 6 irgendwas drauf hatte, also SUSE 6.2 oder so, hat das auch alles ganz nett geklappt mit IP Change. Und jetzt habe ich eine aktuelle Reversion installiert, ich glaube 9.0. Jetzt ist er auf ITP-Tables umgestellt und da ist es ganz komisch. Und zwar sind da zig Seiten voll von diesen Einträgen, welche Pakete alles geblockt werden. Und ich kriege das auch nicht hin, dass ich nur noch meine, was ich 20 habe, die ich brauche.
Na, das ist dann aber ein Problem von SUSE. Wenn ich vielleicht an der Stelle was über meinen Hintergrund sagen darf, ich bin einer der wesentlichen Mitentwickler von diesen IT-Tables, das du eben einsetzt auf deinem Rechner. Und dass da so viele Regeln schon standardmäßig mitgeliefert werden bei deiner SUSE Linux-Distribution, das ist ein, ja wie soll ich sagen, ich würde sagen, in deinem Fall ein Problem von SUSE. SUSE würde sicherlich sagen, das ist ein Feature. Wir liefern da schon die Firewall vorkonfiguriert aus. Das ist schon sicher mit der Standardinstallation.
Aber ganz kurz, wie bist du dazu gekommen, so ein externes Gerät aufzusetzen, also ein extra Rechner und Router? War das jetzt so der Spieldrang oder hast du spezielle Anforderungen dran?
Und der Bedarf war auch gegeben, irgendwas zu machen, weil wir eben zwei Rechner haben, die gleichzeitig im Internet sein sollen.
Vielleicht noch kurz zur Terminologie wieder. Was ist nun ein Hub? Ein Hub ist also nichts anderes als ein Verteiler, eine Verteiler-Steckdose. Sowas wie eine Dreifach-Steckdose für den Strom, eben auch für Netzwerkkabel. An der Stelle, weil wir gerade irgendwie hier von altes, neues Linux waren, ist vielleicht ein Aufknüpfpunkt, wo man nochmal den Paketfilter etwas ansprechen kann. Da kann man dann wieder differenzieren zwischen dem sogenannten State-less-Paketfilter und dem sogenannten State-full-Paketfilter. Das ist also ein technologischer Unterschied, wie diese Pakete dort gefiltert werden. Die Details möchte ich euch jetzt ersparen. Nur ist es eben so, dass sich in den letzten Jahren das sogenannte State-full-Paketfilter durchgesetzt hat und Linux-Systeme, die Kernel 2.4 oder neuer haben, bringen den eben von Haus aus mit. Ältere Systeme haben eben noch so einen älteren Paketfilter. Auch die Konfiguration von der neuen Technik ist deutlich einfacher.
Und wie krieg ich das hin, dass das übersichtlich ist und ich nur meine 20 Regeln hinschreibe?
Na ja, ich würde einfach sagen, du deaktivierst diese Scripts, die Susi mitliefert, die diese ganzen Regeln setzen und du schreibst dir dein eigenes, wo nur deine Regeln drinstehen.
Na, dieses Script......ist dann auch mit abgeschaltet.
Nein, nein, dieses Script, das ist irgendwo in etc, rcd, initd in diesem Verzeichnis und das musst du eben dann dort deaktivieren oder eben deinem Susi beibringen, du willst keine Firewall und das dann eben von Hand konfigurieren.
Mhm, da hatte ich versucht, da hatte ich das Problem, wie ich die Weiterleitung mache, weil ja zwei Netzerkarten drin sind und mit IP Change ging das noch relativ einfach, einfach Masquerading anschalten oder so. Könnt ihr mir sagen, wie ich das jetzt mache?
Das heißt immer noch Masquerading bei IP Tables und ich denke, wir sollten an der Stelle dann mal den Support irgendwie wieder einstellen, weil ich glaube die meisten Hörer langweilt das dann doch etwas im Detail. Aber ich würde dir einfach mal empfehlen im Netz zu suchen, einfach irgendwie nach IP Tables und Masquerading, es gibt da How-To's, es gibt Dokumentationen, es gibt Hilfe Seiten, es gibt Mailinglisten, also du bist da nicht der Erste, der vor dem Problem steht. Und wie gesagt, es heißt immer noch genauso, es heißt immer noch Masquerading.
Du kannst dich hier auch einfach mal in den Chat einklinken, hier wird viel gefragt und geantwortet. Na dann kannst du auf der Wikipedia-Seite nachschlagen, da wird auch das ein oder andere gefragt und beantwortet.
Vielleicht noch schnell, vielleicht hat es dem Mike auch schon was gebracht. Hallo Mike. Will, was über IP-Tables auch?
Ja, ich wollte ja sicher, gerade Stefan, falls du noch Töne hast, pass auf, das ist relativ einfach. Da gibt es ein hervorragendes Buch von Markt- und Technikverlag, das nennt sich Linux Firewalls, Konzentration und Implementierung von Netzwerken und CCs. Ein hervorragendes Buch, danach ist IP-Tables ein Kinderspiel.
Echt, also.
Wir nicken alles stumm.
Doch, das war grad stumm, also.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ja, wunderbar.
Also ich hab auch so inzwischen schon zwei Linux-Surfer in meiner Wohnung stehen, in unserer WG und da läuft hervorragend IP-Tables drauf. Das ist eine feine Sache.
Das freut mich.
Also, und für alle Wintersourcer wollte ich eigentlich sagen, macht euer Norden-Antivirus und Norden-Firewall aus, das ist ganz schlimm. Dafür braucht man eigentlich einen zweiten Rechner, der eigentlich nur diese Firewall und Virusgeschichte macht, weil der Rechner quasi nachher nicht mehr brauchbar ist, wenn das installiert ist. Es gibt also zum Beispiel von der Firma Seagate eine Desktop Firewall, die besser ist.
Also was heißt besser ist, aber...
Warum ist die besser?
Ich finde sie ist einfacher zu konfigurieren. Gerade wenn man einen einzelnen Windows-PC hat mit einem DSL-Modem oder einer ESD-Endkarte, dann ist da übersichtlicher und das System sparen wir, also das Worten sparen wir, als diese Notengeschichte. Und für alle, die einen Stift zur Hand haben, da gibt es noch diese Seite, http://scan.seagate.com und da kann man sich zum Beispiel seinen Rechner scannen lassen und da wird eben eigentlich aufgelegt, wie weit auf so einem Windows-System eigentlich steht, ohne entsprechende Schutzmaßnahmen. Also nochmal scan.seagate.com Ok, ja Norton bietet ja sowas auch an.
Lustigerweise haben wir festgestellt, dass wenn man hinter einem guten Router sitzt, der schon einiges für einen tut, Norton dann immer behauptet, dass man überhaupt nicht ins Internet angeschlossen ist.
Gut, dann würde ich mich auch.
Vielleicht ist man das ja dann auch nicht mehr.
Vielleicht, wo wir gerade am URL durchgeben sind, was wir so letzte Woche gefunden haben oder darauf aufmerksam gemacht wurden, ist eine Seite www.jagan.de, wo jemand sehr liebevoller Schulkinderart beschrieben hat, wie zum Beispiel eine Firewall funktioniert. Ihr werdet amüsiert sein.
Ist großartig.
Können wir das mal vorlesen, wenn das amüsiert ist?
Nein, das kann man nicht vorlesen. Ich kriege es einfach, aber mach vorher Musik an. Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal sagen, dass es...
Ganz kurz, Mike, soweit zufrieden?
Ich bin zufrieden. Ich bin jetzt die Hälfte vergessen, was ich eigentlich noch loswerden wollte. Für alle Leute, die mehr als zwei PCs in der Röhnung stehen haben, sollten sie sich überlegen, ob sie nicht vielleicht einen Mini-Dynos ersetzen. Und auch bitte keine SUSE, weil das hat in meinem Begriff schon nichts mehr mit Linux zu tun. Und auch diese SUSE-Firewall ist gerade für Anfänger da definitiv nicht zu durchschauen. Und dann, wie gesagt, holt euch so ein Buch über IP-Tables und danach, wie gesagt, kann man sich eine hervorragende Firewall bauen. Und letztes Jahr, ich glaube im August war das Quatsch, August, Oktober, wo dieser, wie hieß er, dieser Wurm?
Keine Ahnung.
Der über dieses Netbeers-Protokoll und Port 10930.
MS Blaster war das, oder?
Blaster, genau. Also das war ja, das war für mich, also ich hab nur gelacht. Tagelang hab ich gelacht, wochenlang gelacht. Der Patch war schon lange verfügbar und meine Locks, die sind immer noch, also mündlich vollgelaufen von diesem Wurm da. Also es war goldig anzusehen. Es ist eine feine Sache.
Ja, ich hab da nicht mehr gelacht, weil ich der war, der nicht gelacht hat. Und deswegen haben ganz viele Leute beim Anrufen gesagt, du lachst ja, das muss jetzt aber aufhören, du musst mir nämlich helfen. Da muss man den Leuten helfen. Das ist immer dieser typische, du kennst dich doch mit Computern aus. Das ist immer eine scheiß Frage. Mike, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Du kannst weiter lachen.
Du kennst dich doch mit Computern aus.
Ja, nee, aber das Problem ist, verstehst du, wenn du lachst, wenn alle anderen leiden.
Dann helf mir doch mal.
Verstehst du, das ist so dieses Ding, hör mal, du hast das Problem, wie macht man das denn? Deswegen finde ich es sehr gut, dass wir heute diese Sendung machen, weil jetzt dann weniger Leute nachfragen. Du kennst dich doch mit Computern aus. Das ist ein Scheißsatz, das ist so ein Kribbelsatz, verstehst du?
Da lache ich und sage, ich habe Windows seit neun Jahren nicht mehr angefasst. Ich habe keine Ahnung gefunden, dann lache ich nochmal.
Ja, so rede ich mich auch immer raus, das hilft.
Vielleicht müssen wir noch mal darauf eingehen, warum man eigentlich, selbst wenn man jetzt so einen DSL Router zu Hause hat, der vielleicht auch ein bisschen, also der NAT macht und der auch ein bisschen Firewall hat, also eigentlich können gar keine Verbindungen von draußen reinkommen. Wozu brauche ich auf meinem Windows Rechner denn trotzdem noch irgendwie eine Firewall? Eine Personal Firewall. Also ich muss ja nun gestehen, ich benutze auch Windows hier auf meinem Computer, den ich vor mir habe und ich habe sowas nicht und eigentlich geht es mir auch ganz gut hin. Ich hatte damit auch irgendwie noch keine Probleme gehabt.
Und wieso? Du hast aber dein internes Flag gesetzt, dass bitte das ausgeschaltet werden soll, ein Hacking gemacht oder nicht?
Ich habe, es gibt bei Windows XP als kleines Bordmittel, da braucht man gar kein Produkt extra kaufen, sondern es gibt jedes Netzwerk Interface, das ist die Möglichkeit, eine einfache Verbindungs Firewall zu aktivieren. Das heißt, wenn ich dann Hickchen mache, werden einfach alle Verbindungen von draußen nicht mehr zugelassen. Das kann also jeder ganz einfach machen. Sollte einfach über die Netzwerkeinstellungen, über die Eigenschaften für jedes Netzwerk Interface, also sei es jetzt der Ethernet-Anschluss, der LAN-Anschluss, oder das Modem oder auch eine Wireless-Karte, einfach mal gucken, ob diese Verbindungs Firewall aktiviert ist.
Was ist in dem Fall mit irgendwelchen Chat-Programmen, wie IRC-Chat-Programm oder ICQ-Programm, wo du dann im Internet online bist und so? Weil die auch Ports benutzen, bestimmte, die dann in der Regel gesperrt sind, zumindest für den Zugriff von außen.
Naja, also ich benutze eigentlich nur Java und das funktioniert. Also ich bin auch nicht so der wahnsinnige Chatter und benutze auch keine Voice-over-IP-Geschichten oder so was, sondern ja, bisher habe ich ja keine Probleme. Es gibt allerdings auch die Möglichkeit, Ports von außen aufzumachen dabei, das muss man dann aber von Hand konfigurieren. Da muss man dann schon wissen, welche Ports man öffnen muss oder welches Protokoll, ist das jetzt TCP oder UDP?
Haben wir eigentlich schon dieses Programm erwähnt, was die Ports alle zumacht?
Nee, haben wir noch nicht. Da wollte ich eigentlich auch gleich so drauf hinkommen. Das Problem ist, die Seite ist noch nicht online. Also wir haben als CTC, wo jetzt gerade diese große Sasser-Geschichte war, eine kurze Erinnerung, das ist also ein Wurm, ein kleines Programm, was eine Schwäche ausnutzt eines offenen Ports. Da ist also ein Dienst offen, wo eigentlich dazu gedacht ist, dass andere Computer sich zu meinem Computer verbinden und da irgendwelche Sachen anfragen oder irgendwelche Sachen tun. Und das ist eigentlich etwas, was ich normalerweise als Benutzer nicht brauche, aber trotzdem war Microsoft der Meinung, es müsste offen bleiben. Dieser Dienst müsste von außen vom Rechner aus erreichbar sein. Leider gibt es eine Schwachstelle in diesem Dienst, da gibt es also ein Programmierfehler, sodass es anderen Angreifern erlaubt ist, dann irgendwelche Sachen, die verbinden sich dann bei mir mit dem Rechner, senden dann bestimmte Codes, spezielle Daten, und darauf findet eine Fehlfunktion in diesem Dienst statt, und der Angreifer hat die Möglichkeit, Sachen auf meinem Rechner zu tun, die ich nicht will. Das ist also die Grundidee hinter diesem Sasserwurm. Und was dieser Wurm dann gemacht hat, ist da, ich weiß gar nicht genau, was er gemacht hat, aber er hat jedenfalls Dinge gemacht auf dem Rechner.
Er hat den Computer rauf und runter erfahren, mehr nicht.
Mehr nicht? Dann gab es aber noch die Geschichte mit einem Fettbott, wo irgendwie noch der hinten, der Sasser öffnet das Tor für noch weitere Programme, die noch auf meinen Rechner kommen können.
Der hatte ja auch noch mal einen Bug.
Genau.
Der Sasser. Und dann kam der Fettbott und hat den wiederum ausgenutzt und der war dann halt nicht so...
Man muss dazusagen, dass es sich dabei nicht um irgendwelche filigrane, hochtechnologisch geil programmierte High-End-Scheiße handelt, sondern um wirklich den letzten Dreck, der mit irgendwelchen anderen Programmen Skriptkiddy-mäßig zusammengefrickelt ist.
Hat aber gereicht, um etliche Millionen Computer langzulegen.
Man muss aber auch sagen, dass es mit der Sicherheit ein philosophisches Problem ist. In aller Regel setzen die Anwender, und das weiß auch die Marketing-Abteilung unseres Freundes aus Redmond, Funktionalität über Sicherheit. Ich werde Sicherheit nie bekommen, wenn ich nicht bereit bin, mich damit ein bisschen auseinanderzusetzen oder auf ein bisschen Komfort zu verzichten. Wenn ich immer Funktionalität höher setze als Sicherheit, dann kommen eben so Dinge dabei raus, also wozu brauche ich Scriptfunktionen an einem E-Mail-Client? Oder wozu brauche ich alle möglichen Dinge, die eben eingebaut werden von den großen Softwarefirmen? Da werden einfach Dinge geschrieben, die vielleicht mal nicht irgendwo blinken. Und das ist dann cool und das kann man verkaufen, aber an die Sicherheit wird da halt erst sehr nachrangig gedacht.
Kaum erzähle ich, das ist die Seite online, einfach geht auf www.ccc.de und da gibt es den News-Eintrag Hacker stopfen Windows-Löcher.
Das ist so, dass der Leute in unserem Kreis...
Komm Max, wir müssen uns auf einmal auf B-Zeitungsniveau unternehmen, damit die Leute uns zuhören.
Komm, wir brauchen einen Titel, lass uns mal in die Porno-Abteilung gehen.
Windows-Löcher.
Wenn ich hier vielleicht gerade noch eine Frage aufgreife, die ich gerade im fritz.de vorhin geschrieben hab, da steht jetzt, wozu braucht man eine Firewall? Wenn ich nichts öffne, brauche ich auch kein Programm, das die Ports schließt. Da muss man jetzt irgendwie erst mal sich fragen, was versteht derjenige unter, wenn ich nichts öffne. Es ist halt so, dass alle möglichen... In dem Moment, wo ich so ein Windows- oder ein beliebiges Betriebssystem installiere, dann laufen da so viele Programme im Hintergrund, von denen ich gar keine Ahnung hab, die irgendetwas tun, wo es darum geht, dass automatisch irgendwelche Dinge im Netzwerk funktionieren, oder wo... Ja, also da laufen einfach Dienste im Hintergrund, die nach außen erreichbar sind. Da geht es auch wieder darum, man will irgendwas einfach zum Funktionieren bringen und denkt eben nicht an die Sicherheit, und dann sind da so Dinge wie Laufwerksfreigaben offen nach außen hin, es sind solche Nachrichtendienste, also dass man sich gegenseitig kleine Nachrichten in Fenster schreiben kann und so weiter, sind offen. Da muss ich gar nichts machen, sondern das ist einfach nach der Installation alles offen. Und das ist wieder so eine Strategiefrage. Es gibt zum Beispiel Betriebssysteme wie OpenBSD, die werden installiert und da ist die Default-Einstellung, alles ist zu. Dann funktioniert halt auch erstmal nicht alles. Ich muss dann eben genau das einschalten, was ich tatsächlich brauche, aber dazu muss ich dann erst wissen, was ich brauche. Das ist wieder so ein Usability-Problem. Aber das Argument, ich mache nichts auf, also brauche ich auch keine Firewall, das ist in jedem Fall ungültig.
Der Andreas ist am Telefon, hallo Andreas.
Ich habe mal eine Frage, kann man eigentlich auch Ports manuell schließen? Also was habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel NetBus, 12345, dass man den irgendwie per Registry oder wie auch immer selber schließen kann, halt ohne Firewall? Also dass man nicht der Firewall sagt, wie soll ich den zumachen?
Also ich bin beileibe nicht der Windows Experte, aber im Allgemeinen geht das eigentlich immer nur dadurch, dass du das Programm beendest, dass es diesen Port aufmacht.
Oder den Dienst. Also das ist ja zur Erklärung. Also ein Dienst ist in der Regel etwas, was im Hintergrund läuft. Das heißt, wenn du das Windows bootest, wird es automatisch gestartet, ohne dass du irgendwas anklickst. So dann läuft es halt stillschweigend im Hintergrund und sind zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit, dass andere Leute Dateien auf deinem Rechner zugreifen können. Das ist halt ein Dienst, dieser Freigabendienst, der läuft einfach da. Und dieser Dienst macht dann auch die Ports auf. Das heißt, wenn du verhindern willst, dass die Ports aufgemacht werden, dann kannst du diesen Dienst nur beenden. Also nicht starten oder beenden. So bei Linux oder wenn du halt eine Open-Service-Variante davon hättest, wo du den Quelltext hast, kannst du zum Beispiel auch von Hand eingreifen sagen, okay, das Programm soll zwar laufen, der Dienst, soll aber keine Ports nach außen öffnen. Das wäre denkbar. Nur bei Windows hast du die Optionen nicht.
Ist aber halt ziemlich kompliziert, und das ist in der Regel viel einfacher, einfach irgendwo so ein kleines Kästchen davor zu stellen, die kosten auch eigentlich überhaupt kein Geld mehr, eben einen Paketfilter davor zu stellen, der eben einfach alles blockiert, der einfach bis auf bestimmte Ausnahmen, die ich explizit eintrage, sämtliche Ports sperrt, und damit habe ich das Problem noch nicht. Da kann ich mich dann auch halbwegs darauf verlassen, weil das ist nochmal ein extra Gerät, das ist nicht irgendwo irgendeine Software, die vielleicht auch wieder vom nächsten Windows-Wurm wieder irgendwie umkonfiguriert wird oder was auch immer, sondern es ist einfach nochmal ein Stückchen mehr Sicherheit, dass man da gewinnt.
Naja, aber man kann ja zum Beispiel den Nachrichtendienst dort, ich glaube das ist Port 135, wie auch immer, den kann man ja bei Windows unter Dienste abstellen. Also da hat man ja eigentlich diesen Port selber geschlossen.
Ja, indirekt, weil du den Dienst abgestellt hast. Also, Ports kann nur Software auf und zu machen oder benutzen. Und du musst halt eben diese Software daran hindern, ausgeführt zu werden und dann wird der Port auch nicht mehr benutzt oder geöffnet.
So, dann der Klaus. Nee, Moment, Sekunde Klaus, dauert noch eine Sekunde. René ist am Telefon. Hallo René aus Görlitz.
Guten Abend.
So, also zwei Fragen hätte ich und zwar habe ich einen DSL Router aufgesetzt mit Flee4L oder wie auch immer sich das nennt, wie man es ausspricht. Ihr werdet es sicherlich kennen.
Ja, für die, die es nicht kennen, kannst du vielleicht mal einen Satz drüber erzählen, was es denn ist.
Ja.
Kannst du kurz erzählen, was es ist, dann brauchen wir das nicht mehr.
Also, im Prinzip ist es ein kleines Linux-System auf einer Diskette, was Routing-Funktionen erfüllt. Genau. So, mein Problem oder meine Sorge in dem Moment ist jetzt, dass jetzt auch wirklich die ganze Sache so konfiguriert wurde. Ich meine, man hat ja diese kleine Konfigurationsdatei, wo man drin rumschreibt und so weiter. Und ich denke, ich hab das Ding auch relativ sicher gekriegt. Nur ist ja die Sache, wie erkläre ich das jetzt, ich habe einerseits den Router, auf dem ich die Port sperren kann, dass keiner von draußen reinkommt. Und ich habe die Rechner dahinter, die im Netzwerk sind. Und das ist wieder eine extra Einstellung. Also was da durchgeht. Ich höre euch ganz schlecht irgendwie.
Können wir nicht viel dran ändern?
Es liegt ja dran, dass wir alle mit unseren Computern beschäftigt sind.
Nein, nein, nein. Glaub ich nicht, aber ja, gut.
Jetzt wäre die Frage, wie, also mein eigenes Anliegen ist, im Prinzip die Rechner aus dem Netzwerk, daran zu hindern, Falsch-Sharing-Kram auszuführen, also Kase an Co.
Ja, du möchtest also sozusagen einen Paketfilter haben, der nicht Dinge von außen filtert, sondern eben Dinge filtert, die von innen nach außen gehen, also auf einer logischen Ebene.
Ich will vielleicht den Unterschied auch nochmal erklären, wie das dann letztendlich funktioniert. Ich meine, der Router hat dann letztendlich im Internet die IP, und auf dem Router kann ich praktisch alles zumachen, wo ein Dienst läuft. Ich meine, gut, auf dem Ding läuft momentan nicht viel, maximal auf der 5000, diese Imon-Demon, da ist ja nicht viel zu machen. Aber die Rechner dahinter, das ist ja dann das Problem. Und generell rautet das Ding ja erstmal alles, was ich rausschicke und was wieder reinkommt, was ich anfordere.
Das ist richtig, ja. Wenn man eben über den Router spricht, ist das auch eigentlich das, was er tun soll. Jetzt, wenn du da eine Firewall oder einen Paketfilter drauf hast, dann bei fertigen Geräten kann man das selten konfigurieren, aber wenn man sich selber was zusammen bastelt, dann geht das schon eher, oder ein professioneller das Produkt erwirbt. Dann kann man da sehr wohl auch Filterregeln einstellen für Verbindungen, die von innen nach außen gehen. Man kann dann eben sagen, zum Beispiel, HTTP ist erlaubt, ich kann meinen Webbrowser aufmachen und mir irgendwelche Webseiten angucken, aber ich kann sagen, FDP geht nicht, oder Chat geht nicht, Irg oder was auch immer. Bei den Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerken ist es etwas komplizierter, weil die in der Regel, und da kommen wir zu einem sehr interessanten Thema, auf der Netzwerkebene mehrere Verbindungen aufbauen. Das ist also so, dass ein Webbrowser oder ein FDP-Client oder ein IRG-Client, die machen in aller Regel eine Verbindung irgendwohin auf. Das ist eine sogenannte TCP-Verbindung. TCP ist eines von diesen Netzwerkprotokollen. Und alle Daten werden in dieser einen Verbindung ausgetauscht. Bei diesen P2P-Netzwerken und auch bei Voice-over-IP, also Internet-Telefonie und diversen Spieleprotokollen, ist das so, dass aus Netzwerksicht mehrere Verbindungen aufgemacht werden. Das merkt der Anwender nicht, aber im Hintergrund laufen mehrere Verbindungen auf unterschiedlichen Ports. Und da ist es dann schwierig, insbesondere wenn diese Ports keine festen Nummern haben, zu wissen, was da eigentlich passiert. Der Paketfilter geht ja traditionellerweise her und schaut sich diese Nummer an und sagt, aha, das ist 80, 80 wird für WWW verwendet. Und dann kann ich eben, dadurch, dass ich 80 sperre, aber nur über diese Konvention, dass für WWW üblicherweise 80 verwendet wird, das sperren. Wenn jetzt jemand seinen Webserver auf Port 90 laufen lässt, dann habe ich das nicht damit abgedeckt. Ich gucke mir ja nur die Adressen an, es könnte ja jemand irgendwie andere Adressen drauf schreiben. Um also solche Protokolle zu filtern, die dynamisch irgendwelche Portnummern verwenden, oder wo jemand absichtlich andere Portnummern verwende, da muss ich tatsächlich in den Inhalt hineingucken. Was wird da übertragen? Ist das eine Webseite? Ist das eine Chatverbindung? Was auch immer. Und das sind dann eben in der Regel sogenannte Proxies, die diese Funktion anbieten. Da kommt also ein Paketfilter eigentlich nicht mehr damit klar, sondern da brauche ich dann irgendeinen Proxy, der sich tatsächlich den Inhalt dieser Verbindungen anschaut.
Ist das so übliche Praxis oder ist das jetzt was ganz, ganz Abwegiges?
Das ist nicht so abwegig. Das wird auch unter dem Namen teilweise Application Layer Gateway, teilweise Proxy, dann teilweise noch transparente Proxies oder aber auch Deep Packet Inspection, habe ich auch schon gehört oder was weiß ich was. Es gibt da unterschiedliche Marketingbegriffe dafür. Im Grunde geht es eben darum, ich filtre nicht basierend auf Adressen, sondern ich mache den Briefumschlag auf oder dieses Paket und gucke rein, was ist denn im Paket drin und filtre eben da drauf. Layer 7 Filtering gibt es auch noch.
Content-based Filter. Da kann man sich beliebige Marketing Terms so einfallen lassen, aber es ist halt etwas anderes, ob man sich nur den Umschlag anschaut oder ob man eben auch nochmal reinkommt.
Aber René, brauchst du das überhaupt? Ich meine, wenn du ohnehin nur Web und Mail oder was auch immer zulassen willst, kannst du ja sagen, alle anderen zu, egal welche auch. Und wenn das Programm dann diese ganzen Ports immer verändert ist, ist ja scheißegal.
Naja, das wäre die Frage gewesen, ob ich wirklich, ob ich jetzt das Problem erschlage, indem ich alles zumache, außer die 80.
Tut dir ja nicht weh. Ja, kannst du machen. Du kannst das Problem wirklich tatsächlich damit eben erschlagen, dass du sagst, alles wird gesperrt und ich mach nur noch Port 80 auf und vielleicht noch irgendwie Port 143 für iMap oder was weiß ich was. Also die Protokolle, die ich eben tatsächlich brauche, kann ich aufmachen, vielleicht dann auch am besten noch nur zu dem einen Mailserver, den ich tatsächlich verwende und nicht Internetweit, also man kann das beliebig einschränken. Aber diese Default Closed, also erstmal standardmäßig alles zu und dann nur explizit das aufmachen, was man tatsächlich benutzt, ist sowieso die aufwändigere, aber sicherheitstechnisch sehr viel bessere Strategie als nur bestimmte Dinge zu sperren.
Da können, also ich sag, können diese Personal Firewalls eigentlich auch eine Hilfe sein, weil die ja sehr interaktiv arbeiten. Also je nachdem, wie man sie konfiguriert, aber da kann man ja auch sagen, ich mach jetzt erstmal alles zu und wenn ein Programm hergeht und sagt, jetzt hätte ich aber gerne mal, dann kriegt man das eben angezeigt, nicht selten eben mit dem Hinweis darauf, welches Programm das ist. Das ist also, an sich ist das eine gute Idee, wie die Dinge dann praktisch ausgeführt sind, ist eine ganz andere Frage, aber im Prinzip ist das schon mal nicht schlecht. Insbesondere, wenn sie in der Lage sind, dann eben aus den Einstellungen, die man gemacht hat, auch so eine feste Konfiguration zu generieren, mit der man dann weiter arbeiten kann.
René, war das eine Antwort auf deine Frage?
Ich denke schon, ja. Ich hatte es vielleicht nicht ganz so deutlich formuliert, aber im Prinzip ist es das gut, dann mach ich das Ding halt dicht. Eine kurze Sache noch, und zwar hat ich mir jetzt vor kurzem noch für XP das tolle SubSpect 2 in der Beta-Version gezogen. Und da ist ja jetzt auch, eine gute Firewall war ja schon immer dabei irgendwie, aber jetzt ist er halt richtig offiziell und ganz offensichtlich Bestandteil der ganzen Sache.
Warum hast du dir das denn in der Beta-Version überhaupt gezogen, Samar?
Weil ich neugierig bin.
Ach so.
Windows gibt was die geben.
Bitte keine Diskussion darüber.
Unglaublich.
Dann neu ist ja nur, dass sie die Sachen jetzt auch Beta nennen.
Ach so, sie nennen das...
Es heißt jetzt XP Beta.
Die Frage ist nur, gibt es schon irgendwelche Erfahrungen? Also wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich dieses Teil jetzt drauf hab, kann ich jetzt auf der ganzen Firewall... Ich hatte bis jetzt Zone-Alarm, also das mit dem DSL Router, das ist bei meiner Freundin irgendwo, hatte Zone-Alarm drauf und hab mir jetzt dieses Service Pack geladen und halt mit der Firewall und allem drum und dran. Kann ich jetzt auf die Personal Firewall verzichten? Ist es jetzt insofern wirklich sicher? Gibt es da schon Erfahrungen mit dem Ding? Oder sollte man lieber die Finger davon lassen?
We don't know. Also so neue Software löst vielleicht alte Probleme und schafft neue. Das ist einfach generell immer so. Und es ist nicht schlecht, default paranoid zu sein.
Auch so ganz sicherheitsphilosophisch ist es grundsätzlich sinnvoll, sich nie auf einen Anbieter oder auf überhaupt einen, was auch immer zu verlassen. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie ein Microsoft Betriebssystem hat, dann ist es vielleicht gar nicht so geschickt, von einem anderen Anbieter irgendwie die Firewall zu haben. Nicht, dass man jetzt irgendwie hier irgendwelche Anschuldigungen oder irgendwas erheben will. Aber es gibt ja zum Beispiel zahlreiche Dinge, die auch die die Windows selber tut, zum Beispiel mit dem Media Player, irgendwelche Dinge melden oder wo auch im Prinzip ausspioniert werden kann der Rechner oder wie auch immer. Also es gibt da ja die offsqlusten Dinge, die betrieben werden. Und es ist immer ganz gut, Sicherheit zu verteilen auf unterschiedliche Anbieter oder vielleicht auch unterschiedliche Geräte wie auch immer. Und nicht alles so von einem Anbieter auf einem Gerät. Das ist dann immer zweite Wahl.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass Zone Alarm und auch Cario das schon eine Weile machen und dass das nicht die allererste Version ist aus irgendeiner Beta. Die machen das schon ein Weilchen.
Es kann ja sein, dass das alles ganz toll ist. Aber es kann einfach genauso sein, dass sie wieder neue Probleme schaffen. Von daher können wir einfach so eine pauschale Aussage mit dem Update ist jetzt alles prima. Einfach nicht fällen.
Außerdem gibt es noch keine Erfahrungen damit.
Genau, gerade wenn es frisch ist.
Ok René.
Viel Spaß. Danke euch und wünsche euch noch schönen Abend.
Der Klaus ist am Telefon. Klaus, bist du da?
Ja, ich bin noch da.
Ah, aus der Schweiz, aus Dübendorf.
Genau, ich höre euch übers Internet, über Impact Stream. Und ja, was mich stört eigentlich immer ein bisschen, wenn ich höre, dass da jetzt die Windows User, nenne ich sie mal in Handführungszeichen, ihr Personal Firewall einsetzen und jetzt sich so drauf verlassen, dass diese Personal Firewalls ihnen alle Probleme wegnimmt. Und ja, auch die Fragen, wo ich jetzt von anderen Leuten gehört habe bis heute, ging auch schon teilweise in die Richtung. Und zwar, ich denke mal, es ist nicht nur Windows Leute, aber da ist das Problem halt eher gepusht. Da ist auch Microsoft ja mittlerweile so ein Firewall mitgeliefert, in dem dann ihre eigene Software noch Löcher reinbohrt. Und ich wollte einfach mal hören, was ihr davon haltet. Und wie ihr das seht, ob ihr das genauso seht, oder ob ihr das Problem ganz anders seht.
Gut, bevor wir die Frage beantworten, sagen wir noch mal kurz, wie wir sind. Ihr hört nämlich das Chaosradio auf Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Frank, Harald und Tim sind im Studio und meine Person der Max und es geht um Firewalls und Co. So und jetzt können wir.
Die Frage, ob Personal Firewalls sinnvoll sind oder nicht, wird sowohl im Netz als auch bei uns im Club intern irgendwie ziemlich heftig, ziemlich kontrovers diskutiert. Da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche Ansichten. Der eine Aspekt ist natürlich, dass Personal Firewall erstmal das Schlimmste verhindern kann. Das können wir mit Sicherheit mal so sagen. Aber es hat natürlich auch das Problem, dass die Leute sich dann zurücklehnen und sagen, ich hab ja so eine Firewall, mir kann nichts passieren. Und genau dann aufhören, sich jegliche Gedanken zu machen, was mit ihrem Rechner passiert, was da noch im Internet unterwegs ist und was noch auf sie zukommen kann. Das heißt, so eine Personal Firewall ist halt so wie im Prinzip das Gehirn an der Garderobe abzugeben. In dem Moment, wenn man sich drauf verlässt, dass es wirklich alles sicher macht, diesen ganzen Rechner absichert und Windows dann plötzlich wie eine Festung ist, die dann nicht mehr eingenommen werden kann.
Das kann man vielleicht auch wieder auf eine sicherheitsphilosophische Sache reduzieren, dass Sicherheit nie ein Produkt ist, sondern Sicherheit ein Prozess ist. Den muss ich immer beobachten und ich muss mich kümmern. Ich kann nie Sicherheit kaufen und kann mich dann vielleicht in Sicherheit wiegen, aber sicher ist es dann immer noch nicht.
Ja und wie weit sieht es aus, dass sich jeder seinen eigenen Firewall zusammenschustert und sich das Know-how selber aneigen muss, oder dass ich in Anführungszeichen mal einen Profi hole, der sich auch darum kümmert und den mir einrichtet.
Ich meine, wenn du einen Profi in deinem Umfeld hast, dann ist es sicherlich kein Fehler, ihn zu fragen. Auch kein Fehler ist es bei mir im Umfeld.
Das ist bei meinen Bekannten immer, wenn sie Probleme in der Richtung haben.
Das mag es Problemen.
Privat ist das natürlich immer ein bisschen so eine Sache. Klar, wenn man jemanden kennt, dann kann man das machen. Das ganze Know-how sich selber anzueignen, ist auch nicht sicherlich jedermanns Sache. Bei Firmen ist es aber in jedem Fall anzuraten, dass man sich da irgendwie einen externen Consultant holt, der irgendwie Erfahrungen damit hat und solche Firewalls dann entsprechend einrichten kann.
Und auch nicht betriebsblind ist, was ja auch ein großes Problem ist.
Und sich auch nicht vom Chef reinreden lässt.
Ja und ich denke mir auch, da kommt es dann auch darauf an, dass die Firmen eigentlich auch das Bewusstsein haben, dass da die Sicherheit sinnvoll ist und überhaupt notwendig ist.
Ja gut, ich glaube, das haben jetzt alle Firmen mittlerweile begriffen nach den jüngsten großen Würmern und Viren und was weiß ich was, dass man sich irgendwie bei Sicherheit Gedanken machen muss. Ich glaube, das ist dadurch irgendwie hinreichender.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, ob da die Schmerzen schon hoch genug waren bei den einzelnen Managern. Schmerzen in puncto Geld, das sie verloren haben. Da sieht das auch absichern, insofern habe ich da noch meine Bedenken.
Das große Problem, dass wir eben auch als CCC-Mann dabei sehen, dass dann der Autor von so einem Virus oder dass irgendwelche solche Leute dann verklagt werden oder dass die als der große Buhmann oder eben genau, also ich meine, das Problem sind die Firmen die oder müssen ja keine Firmen sein, aber sind diejenigen, die die Software so fehlerhaft schreiben und zur Verfügung stellen und nicht die Leute, die dann die Fehler finden.
Ja, gut, die haben auch eine gewisse Schuld, aber die Hauptschuld, denke ich mal, liegt auf jeden Fall bei den Leuten, die die Software entwickeln, also die fehlerhafte Software schreiben.
Und die Leute, die dann gutgläubig trotz im Netz verbreiteten, besseren Expertenwissens, sich nicht hinreichend absichern zusätzlich zu dem, was sie eben an Software installiert haben.
Ja, eben dahingehend ging ja auch meine Frage einfach. Gut, das ist jetzt der Firmenbereich, aber auf dem privaten Bereich sieht es ja ganz ähnlich aus. Eben, dass die Leute dann zwar unter Umständen was installieren oder dann, habe ich auch schon vorher gehört von jemandem, von wegen über 56k saugen. Ich meine, ich werde mir nicht mein neuestes Windows Update von 56 Megabyte oder wie viel sind, über eine 56k Leitung ziehen oder...
Hat derjenige ja auch nicht gemacht.
Ja eben, oder auch einen Vionscanner oder sowas. Oder die Updates über eine kleine Leitung ziehen, das kann ich machen, wenn ich DSL habe oder Cablecom oder etwas entsprechendes, aber nicht, wenn ich eine kleine, schmale Bandbreite habe. Und ich denke, da ist auch die Gefahr dann gegeben, dass ein halbes Jahr, ich habe hier den Filter und ich habe hier den Vionscanner und der ist sicher in Ordnung. Das funktioniert jetzt und warum soll ich dann wieder den Aufwand...
Na gut, es gibt die Alternative, sich die Windows CD mit dem Update halt mit einer Zeitschrift zum Beispiel zu holen oder, keine Ahnung, da selber vorbeizulaufen. Aber ich meine, wenn man nichts tut, dann passiert halt auch nichts.
Also mich wundert auch immer, dass die Leute das bei Computern so anders sehen. Wenn ich irgendwie sonst irgendwas Zylinderschloss an meiner Wohnungstür habe, sondern nur ein Bartschloss, dann wird meine Hausratversicherung nicht mal zahlen und dann was auch immer. Dann ist es nicht mal hinreichend.
Ich mag Bartschlösser.
Ja, schön, dass du die magst. Deine Versicherung magst du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich habe ja noch einen Zylinderschloss da drunter.
Ja eben, genau. Und warum machen die Leute das mit ihren PCs nicht anders? Also ich meine, da muss ich auch irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass das irgendwie halbwegs abgesichert ist. Einbrechen kann dann immer noch jemand. Auch im Zylinderschloss ist das recht leicht, wie die Freunde von den Sportfreunden der Sperrtechnik immer wieder vorführen.
Warum PCs denn überhaupt Haustüren?
Ja, das ist die nächste Frage.
Du willst ja kommunizieren.
Ich denke, da ist einfach auch das Verständnis, was auch auf der Firmenebene schon gar nicht da ist und auf der Privatebene auch gar nicht da ist.
Ja gut, dann darf ich aber ja nicht immer schreien und ach, was hab ich für Verluste gemacht und so weiter. Mein Gott, dann bin ich halt irgendwie auch selber schuld, weil ich mich nicht informiert hab.
Ja eben, aber ich höre solche Schreie immer öfters.
Es ist ja auch sehr bequem zu schreien. Es ist sehr bequem, nach Microsoft zu schreien, beziehungsweise nach den Virenautoren, nicht nach Microsoft. Das ist ja das Problem, wenn alle nach Microsoft schreien, werden wir ja auch weiter. Das Problem ist, dass alle der böse Virenautor schreien. Wie kann der nur? Und wir haben so und so viel Schaden.
Ja, das ist ja auch einfacher.
Ja, es ist sicherlich kein feiner Zug von den Jungs, so böse Programme zu schreiben. Aber es ist halt das alte Ding mit dem nicht abgeschlossenen Auto auf der großen Straße, so.
Ja, vor allem es öffnet auch die Augen. Also es ist ja gar nicht mal, dass die Leute selber schuld sind. Also es wird ihnen ja wirklich einmal klar vor Augen geführt, wie unsicher dieses Ding ist. Und es hätte ja schlimmer, was kommt denn? Also mein Gott, da ist halt ein 18-jähriger Schüler, der hat irgendwie lange Weile und spielt da ein bisschen rum und fährt halt mal ein paar Millionen Computer runter. Das ist ja noch relativ harmlos im Vergleich zu dem, was hätte passieren können.
Man sollte sich aber auch immer wieder klar machen, dass die Zahl bei Windows von Viren und Würmern und Angriffen, die ist extrem hoch. Und bei den anderen Systemen, die so verbreitet sind, ist sie fast nicht messbar.
Aber wenn du sagst, so verbreitet sind die Systeme, dann im Endeffekt nicht.
Na ja, da gibt es auch schon Millionen von Installationen.
So ist es nicht. Auch wenn ich mein SUSE installiere, sage ich mal, und mit SUSE dann ein Firewall mitgeliefert wird, wiege ich mich doch auch in einer gewissen Sicherheit und sage mir, mir kann nichts passieren, ich habe hier ein Firewall laufen.
Ich sage ja nicht, da kann nichts passieren. Passieren kann selbstverständlich auf allen Systemen was, weil das ist Software und Software ist einfach per se anfällig. Allerdings hast du natürlich bei Open Source Systemen einen ganz anderen Review Prozess. Microsoft kümmert sich immer nur um das, was sie daran hindert, noch mehr Geld zu verdienen. Im Linux Bereich im Besonderen, das gilt auch für alle anderen Open Source Betriebssysteme, das sind ja sowieso mittlerweile fast alle außer Windows, ist es eben so, dass diese potenziellen Sicherheitslücken schon bevor es passiert unter Umständen herausgefunden werden, weil sich die Leute einfach den Code angucken. Das resultiert in einer messbaren, höheren Qualität. Die ist nicht unfehlbar, aber die zeigt schon doch deutliche Auswirkungen.
Da rennst du bei mir absolut offene Türen ein. Ich hab auch bei mir zu Hause irgendwo irgendein Microsoft Software laufen. Zumindest mal keines, wo ich mich dran erinnern könnte, dass ich die laufen hätte. Aber die Gefahr ist einfach auch, dass das Betriebssystem Linux auch verwindowsiert wird. Dass da quasi Funktionen eingebaut werden, eine gleiche Selbstverständlichkeit eingebaut wird.
Vor allem mit zunehmender Verbreitung wird es ja auch interessanter für Angreifer oder Programmierer.
Richtig, aber was ich da immer wieder anbringen kann, ist diese Monokulturdebatte. Das hat nichts mit Computersicherheit zu tun, sondern das ist generell so. Wenn ich weltweit nur noch eine Sorte Weizen ansehen würde, und dann gäbe es irgendwie einen Schädling oder was auch immer, dann habe ich halt ein Problem. Diversität statt Monokultur bringt immer grundsätzlich eine gewisse größere Robustheit. Was ich da baue, wenn ich weltweit nur ein Betriebssystem einsetze oder weltweit was auch immer nur in einer Form tue, dann habe ich einen Single Point of Fail da, wie man das bezeichnet, im Sicherheitsbereich. Und wenn der dann irgendwann mal, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, fehlerhaft ist oder korrumpiert wird, dann habe ich halt ein Problem. Und das nicht nur auf 10% der Systeme, sondern eben auf allen.
Klaus, danke dir erstmal für den Anruf. Es sind noch ganz viele in der Leitung.
Ja, ich bedanke mich.
Schönen Gruß an die Schweiz.
Da bekomme ich immer einen Connection Refused.
ircprinode.net Also der Server ist sicherlich nicht deutlich überlastet. Das kann ich nicht sehen. Da sind eine ganze Menge Leute im Chat.
Das ist auch eigentlich irgendwie ein Round-Robin-DNS für die Leute, die wissen, was das heißt.
Das könnte auch ein Firewall-Problem sein.
Du kannst aber auch einfach mal auf die Homepage von dem Freenode-Netzwerk schauen. Da haben die auch die Adressen der einzelnen Server veröffentlicht und nicht nur diesen Round-Robin-DNS-Namen. Viel Spaß.
Tschüss, Klaus.
Bis am Abend noch.
So, kommen wir mal zu was ganz Einfachen. Der Gregor aus Friedrichshain. Hallo, Gregor.
Einen schönen guten Abend, ihr alle.
Also, ich habe jetzt hier meinen ersten Computer nach 24 Jahren mir gekauft und habe den seit November und bis das Modem lief, dauert auch bis Januar. Und ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht so angegriffen und bin auch ganz zufrieden mit Norton Firewall. Es ist alles so eingestellt, weil ich habe ja keine Ahnung. Und es gibt glaube ich ganz, ganz viele User, so wie ich, also das sind die ganzen Lidl-Computerkäufer oder so, die kaufen sich das und benutzen das einfach so. Und ich glaube, ich bin auch so einer. Ich habe es mir aber vom Freund halt alles bauen lassen und mit Wärmeleitpaste einen Prozessor gekauft und schnick und schnack und läuft alles super. Und ich habe halt trotzdem, glaube ich, nur acht Prozent Ahnung von einem Computer oder vielleicht noch weniger. Du bist ja ganz natürlich.
Du gehst über Modem denn ins Internet, oder?
Ja genau, über so ein 56 Kilobyte Modem.
Okay, was ist deine Frage?
Ich habe mich so überlegt und man geht ja über so ein, ich gehe halt über den Explorer rein. Ganz normal, was du vorhin zahliertest. Ich habe auch Windows 2000 und ich habe mir überlegt, also mir wurde auch gesagt, nimm einfach ein anderes Programm, was schlauer ist und besser ist und nicht dieses Muffin-Commerce. Können die mir da weiterhelfen?
Also für Windows kann ich ja uneingeschränkt empfehlen Mozilla. Mozilla, Mozilla Firefox. Pass auf, geh mal einfach auf www.ccc.de und www.ccc.de wie Chaos Computer Club. Und da ist ein Artikel gleich vorne, wo es um diese besagte Hacker stopfen Windows-Löchern. Und da sind auch diese Alternativ-Browser und auch ein alternatives Mail-Programm verlinkt.
Mozilla, muss man dazu sagen, ist ein sehr großes Open-Source-Projekt, die sich halt der Entwicklung von Web-Browsern widmen. Da gibt es mehrere. Firefox ist derjenige, der derzeit sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit generiert, zu Recht, und der auch eine gute Alternative zum Internet-Explorer darstellt. Nicht nur, dass er sich besser bedienen lässt, sondern...
Also eine sehr gute.
Ja, eine...
Ja, ein Ultra-Router, ein super-mega-Ultra-Router.
Also hat sicherlich auch seine Schwächen, aber hat auch auf jeden Fall seine Vorteile.
Auf Arbeit nehmen wir den auch, ich glaube, weil unsere Computer sind mit dem vernetzt. Also, das ist ein kleiner Drache der Feuerspeit, oder?
Und den ein runterladen. Genau, das ist kostenlos, kannst du ja runterladen. Zu dieser Mozilla-Geschichte, das war also vorher ein großer Browser, ein ziemlich fettes Ding, wo Browser, Mail und, ich glaube, eine Chat-Funktion und alles zusammen war. Und das wird jetzt aber gerade aufgesplittet, weil Leute haben gemerkt, okay, das ist irgendwie, manche brauchen nur den Browser, manche brauchen nur ein Mail-Programm. Da gibt es dann ein Mail-Programm, das ist dann der... Thunderbird und der Firefox ist der Browser. Und das Mail-Programm von dem Mozilla Projekt ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr, sehr empfehlenswerte Alternative zum Outlook Express, was ja auch standardmäßig installiert ist. Und Outlook Express ist auch sehr bekannt dafür, irgendwelche Mail-Attachments zu öffnen, beziehungsweise irgendwelche Sachen, die da drin enthalten sind, obwohl man das gar nicht wollte. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile alles gefixt ist, kann ich nichts zu sagen, aber es gibt mit Sicherheit immer noch irgendwelche Löcher und wichtig ist halt, dass das Mail-Programm auch wirklich den User nochmal darauf hinweist, wenn jetzt ein gefährliches Attachement aufgemacht wird, so bist du dir sicher, was du hier tust. Und auch das macht das Mail-Programm von dem Mozilla Projekt.
Gregor, zufrieden?
Ja, ich denke mal, werde ich mich informieren, schauen, laden und probieren.
Weil wir jetzt natürlich gerade merken, dass das sehr allgemein wird und generell um Sicherheit geht. Vielleicht nochmal, die Sache geht um Firewalls und ist natürlich ein sehr kompliziertes Thema. Und wenn schon mal die Jungs vom Chaos Computer Club da sind, kann man ja auch mal generell Sicherheitsfragen stellen. Aber es wäre schon geil, wenn wir uns dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen ums Thema Firewalls noch mehr kümmern würden, weil ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier Christian noch im Telefon hab, der sich über, der sich einen Dialer eingefangen hat. Ist das richtig, Christian? Christian ist nicht mehr am Telefon, okay. Also nicht unbedingt jetzt alles in Sachen Sicherheit. Vielleicht können wir ja noch ein bisschen spezifischer auf das nächste Thema eingehen in Sachen Firewalls.
Das nächste Thema. Naja, wir wollten ja... Also wir haben uns bei der Planung der Sendung, wir wollten sozusagen den Problembereich Internetanschluss und wie kann ich zu Hause mein Heimnetz oder eben auch in der Uni oder im Büro so gestalten, dass ich da Spaß habe und da kommen natürlich auch noch ein paar andere Begriffe mit rein. Eine Abkürzung, mit der man es auch recht häufig zu tun hat, die nicht unbedingt jedem was sagt, ist DHCP. Das steht für Dynamic Host Configuration Protocol, also ein dynamisches Konfigurationsprotokoll, um seinen eigenen Computer zu konfigurieren für den Zugang zum Internet. Wenn man heute so eine kleine Box kauft oder mit seinem Internetanschluss vielleicht gleich noch mit dazu bekommt, dann haben wir ja schon gesagt, das ist ein Router, der leitet erstmal die Pakete rein. Er hat unter Umständen auch eine Firewall-Funktion in der einen oder anderen Art. Er hat häufig, also in der Regel, ein NAT, setzt also die eine IP-Adresse, die man von dem Internet Service Provider dynamisch zugeteilt bekommt, so um, dass man eben auch mehrere Computer dahinter problemlos oder mehr oder weniger problemlos betreiben kann. Und außerdem leistet er in der Regel diesen DHCP-Dienst, der dazu führt, dass ich meinen Computer auch nicht besonders konfigurieren muss, sondern man steckt meistens das Kabel rein oder das Ganze geht heutzutage auch über WLAN und dann bekommt man eben diese Adresse automatisch zugeteilt. Sehr häufig ist das unproblematisch, aber bisweilen ist es auch problematisch. Vielleicht sollte man mal kurz erläutern, wie das genau funktioniert.
Ja, ist im Prinzip relativ einfach.
Müsste gehen.
Wie das meiste ja doch eigentlich prinzipiell alles relativ einfach ist. Das heißt es ist so richtig.
Für unsere Maßstäbe.
Ich stecke also meinen Rechner oder meinen Notebook, was auch immer, stecke ich ans Netzwerk. Und dann schickt er eine Anfrage. Diese Anfrage wird als sogenannte Broadcast verschickt. Das ist also ein Paket, das nicht zwischen zwei Rechner kommuniziert wird, sondern das von einem Rechner kommt und an alle anderen Rechner im Netzwerk verschickt wird. Und alle anderen Rechner schließt diesen Router eben mit ein, der als sogenannte DHCP Server funktioniert. Der empfängt dieses Paket und sagt ach, da fragt jemand nach einer IP-Adresse, guckt dann in der Tabelle nach, welche ist denn noch frei, und schickt dann ein Antwortpaket zurück mit dieser freien IP-Adresse.
Das Spannende dabei ist natürlich, wenn der noch gar keine IP-Adresse hat, woher weiß er denn, wo er es hinschicken muss. Also dazu müssen wir vielleicht noch eine Schicht tiefer gehen, das ist dann auf das Ethernet, also das Netzwerk, und da gibt es dann auch nochmal Adressen, das sind dann die Geräteadressen der Netzwerkkarte, damit innerhalb des Netzwerkes dann auch dieser DHCP Server weiß, an welchen Computer er die IP-Adresse zurückschicken muss, weil er in dem Moment noch keine.
Ich vergleiche das mal gerne mit dem großen Flur. Jeder Rechner, der da ist, ist sozusagen ein Raum, der eine Tür zu diesem Flur hat. Und wenn man sozusagen denjenigen erreichen will, der einem etwas zuteilt, dann macht man einfach die Tür auf und schreit Hallo, gib mir doch mal eine IP-Adresse, ich bin sowieso. Und dann macht halt der DHCP Server sein Türchen auf und antwortet halt entsprechend. Und der hat eben die Übersicht, welche Adressen schon ausgeteilt worden sind und vergibt eine noch nicht vergebene. Das ist eigentlich so das Bild, mit dem sie es ganz gut machen. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass wenn man jetzt so einen Heimrouter verwendet, bestimmte IP-Adressen sehr häufig sichtbar sind. Also ich wiederhole es gerne nochmal, diese 192.168.irgendwas oder auch 10.irgendwas, die sind halt sehr häufig. Das ist also in der Regel ein Adressbereich, aus dem man eben auch vom DHCP Server eine Adresse zugeteilt bekommt. Viele Leute, das habe ich gemerkt, haben dann immer so das Problem, dass sie zwar auch eine IP-Adresse sehen und glauben, dass sie ihnen zugeteilt worden ist, die fängt dann mit 169 an. Das ist aber dann dieser spezielle Adressbereich, den ein Computer automatisch selbst verwendet, wenn er eben keinen Kontakt zu diesem DHCP Server hergestellt bekommen hat. Leider sind die meisten Betriebssysteme dann auch nicht besonders eloquent, um diesen Fall ausreichend zu dokumentieren. Das ist schade, sollte sich auch auf jeden Fall verbessern, aber so ist es nun mal. Das heißt, wenn ihr so eine 169er Adresse auf einmal auf eurem Computer vorfindet, dann hat das meistens damit zu tun, dass dieser DHCP Server nicht funktioniert, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Meistens hat man ja sogar Schwierigkeiten, ob man überhaupt so eine Nummer vergeben bekommen hat und wo sie sich befindet. Meistens ist das irgendwo vergrabene Netzwerkeinstellungen und früher war das jetzt bei Windows XP geht es einigermaßen, aber früher war das überhaupt nicht zu finden. Da musste man sich noch ein extra Tool runterladen, was dann festgestellt hat, wie die eigene IP überhaupt ist.
Auf dem Mac ist es mittlerweile ganz angenehm. Also unter Mac OS 10.3, das aktuelle, da ist es sehr schick gelöst. In diesem Netzwerkkontrollfeld zeigt er einem genau für jedes einzelne Interface, also für das Ethernet oder auch für den WLAN-Pod, also AirPod heißt das ja auf dem Mac, zeigt er immer an, ob da schon eine Verbindung überhaupt ist und auch welche IP-Adresse man zugeteilt bekommt und ob die sich selbst zugeteilt hat, also ob das die 169er-Adresse ist oder ob es eine wirklich tatsächlich von einem DHCP-Server automatisch zugeteilte Adresse ist. Und das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein sehr hilfreicher Ansatz. Sehr verbreitet sind ja heutzutage auch diese WLAN-Router. WLAN steht für Wireless LAN, also kabelloses Netzwerk. Sollte euch mal jemand versuchen, ein WLAN-Kabel anzudrehen, dann dürft ihr beherzt anfangen zu lachen, sowas gibt es nicht. WLAN ist natürlich ganz schön, gerade zu Hause, weil man mit seinem Laptop beliebig durch die Gegend marschieren kann und dann eben auch Internet auf dem Klo hat. Es mag ja Situationen geben, wo man nicht so schnell wieder davon zurückkommt. Dann ist WLAN einfach eine tolle Sache.
Jetzt bitte keine fetische Geschichten-Themen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich wollte schon abschweifen. Aber das birgt auch gewisse Risiken. Da ja teilweise auch schon der Nachbar unter Umständen auch WLAN hat, dann kommt das irgendwie schnell mal durch. Die Problematiken, die da entstehen, die können wir gleich noch mal schildern nach der Pause für die Nachricht.
Genau, die machen wir nämlich jetzt mal auf die Schnelle.
Wenn Fritz in Strausberg ist, dann 102, 6.
Wir haben es 23.31 Uhr.
Fritz Info.
So, das Wetter, die Nacht ist bewölkt und es kann vereinzelt Schauer geben. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 3 Grad. Auch morgen soll es regnen, vereinzelt sogar Gewitter geben. Die Temperaturen erreichen 13 bis 15 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Christoph von Greiter.
Der mit Haftbefehl gesuchte Islamist Metin Kaplan ist nach Angaben der Polizei untergetaucht. Die Polizei wollte ihn in Abschiebehaft nehmen. Kurz zuvor hatte das Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster entschieden, dass es keine Hinderungsgründe für eine Ausweisung Kaplans in die Türkei gebe. Die USA fahnden nach sieben verdächtigen Al-Kaida-Mitgliedern. Sie sollen einen Terroranschlag in den Vereinigten Staaten planen. Das gab US-Justizminister F. Croft bekannt. Demnach stellen die Verdächtigen eine klare und aktuelle Gefahr für die USA da. Verteidigungsminister Struck lässt Berichte über angebliche Folterungen im Kosovo prüfen. Nach Angaben der Bildzeitung sollen bei der KV-Truppe Fotos kursieren, die Folterszenen deutscher Soldaten zeigen. Das Verteidigungsministerium hat diese Gerüchte als haltlos bezeichnet. Und zum Sport. Der FC Porto hat die UEFA Champions League gewonnen. Der portugiesische Meister besiegte im Finale in der Arena auf Schalke den AS Monaco mit 3 zu 0. Für Porto ist es der größte Erfolg in der Vereinsgeschichte. Und der Verkehr auf Fritz. A10 östlicher Berliner Ring, Schwanenberg Richtung Spreeau. Zwischen Freienbrink und Spreeau gibt es Behinderungen durch ein defektes Fahrzeug. Der rechte Fahrstreifen ist blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin. Die B1 Mühlendamm-Gruner-Straße ist zwischen Kreuzung Strahlower Straße und der Kreuzung Karl-Marx-Allee gesperrt. Dort finden Instandhaltungsarbeiten statt. Und das noch bis 4 Uhr früh, ansonsten eine gute Fahrt.
Young Life, die Jugendmesse in Frankfurt oder Fritz präsentiert. Drei Tage Bands und Action mit Mia und SPNX. Mit dem Fritz-Schulradio-Netzwerk und mit jeder Menge Infos von A wie Ausbildung bis Z, wie zum Beispiel Medienberufe bei Fritz. Young Life, die Jugendmesse vom 3. Juni auf dem Messegelände Frankfurt oder mehr Infos fritz.de und im Radio.
So, ich muss mal ganz kurz mit dem CD-Player hier reden. So, hier Fritz, das Chaos Radio. Halbzeit ist geschafft, anderthalb Stunden noch Talk hier auf Fritz. 0371 77 91 110 ist die Nummer. Thema heute Abend, Schutz des eigenen Rechners, wenn man ins Internet gehen will oder des Rechnernetzwerkes, Firewalls und Co. Und am Telefon ist der Sebastian aus Cottbus. Hallo Sebastian.
Also nachdem ich jetzt gleich durchgekommen bin, hab ich dann doch letzten Endes fast ne Stunde noch warten müssen, aber das macht ja nix.
Du, das ist immer so umfangreich und wenn ich bei dir den Satz lese, hat gerade versucht, auf Linux umzusteigen, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das entweder in drei Minuten geklärt ist oder auch ne halbe Stunde dauert.
Länger, also wenn ich jetzt alles berichte, was mir dabei aufgefallen bzw.
Was hat das mit Firewalls? Vielleicht könnten wir das da noch beschränken, was es konkret mit Firewalls zu tun hat, was du beschreiben möchtest.
Ja, jetzt ist das andere. Ich hab natürlich noch gar nicht gewusst, dass es konkret um Firewalls geht, als ich heute. Ich hab nicht ganz am Anfang eingeschalten und dann war das dann, naja, aber ist ja auch egal.
Na dann pick dir doch mal das Schönste raus.
Ich pick immer mal das Schönste raus. Also ich habe in so einem Forum einfach mal gelesen, Windows ist wie ein Schweizer Käse, hat ganz viele Löcher gerade in Sicherheit und mit dem Zusammenhang und da hab ich mir gedacht, mein Gott, irgendwie haben sie ja recht, die Leute haben mir das durch den Kopf gehen lassen, hab gedacht, jetzt hast du schon so viel von Linux gehört, probierst du es einfach mal. Ich mir also aus dem Internet so eine aktuelle Distribution rausgezogen von Mandrake oder Mandrake oder wie man das auch mal ausspricht und das auf meinen Rechner drauf geknallt. Windows gleich runter, weil wenn, dann mach ich's richtig, hab ich mir gedacht, naja, dann ging das große los. Dann hat das Programm gefehlt und dies und jenes, einiges war auf den CDs mit drauf, anderes wieder weniger und dann hab ich versucht, das nach zu installieren.
Und da kam der große Hammer.
Wie installiert man Programme unter Linux?
Ja, das ist aber wirklich nun, also nun gar nicht das Thema dieser Sendung. Wir möchten eigentlich auch keine allgemeine Betriebssystemkriegsdiskussion und was ist besser und was ist sicherer für uns, sondern wir haben wirklich tatsächlich irgendwie Firewalls heute Abend, das tut mir leid.
Dann überbringe ich mal ein paar Kapitel und komm zu einem anderen Punkt, ja?
Also grundsätzlich als Empfehlung würde ich gerade bei Linux echt sagen, ein gutes, dickes Buch kaufen zu dem Thema und einfach mal lesen, lesen, lesen, weil sowas dann über das Internet und über irgendwelche kleinen Seiten und so, da sollte man wirklich umfassendes dann lesen, wenn man gerade eingestellt ist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also es gibt vielleicht mal als Tipp, so linuxwiki.org, das sind solche Wiki-Systeme, die gerade diese Fragen, gerade die ersten Fragen einfach gut beantworten.
Nein, also ich dann Linux von Susi installiert und dann hat mich gleich da so ein grünes Ausrufezeichen, oder war es ein I oder keine Ahnung, hat mich angeblinkt und da stand was von Susi Update und bleiben sie immer auf dem neuesten Stand und da hab ich gedacht, mein lieber Schwann, das erinnert mich sehr arg an die Windows Update Funktionen, da wo alle immer schimpfen, dass ich was ganz Böses mache, das bläut nicht. Gut, ich hab das ausgeschalten, aber wie kann ich mir jetzt bei Linux zum Beispiel sicher sein, dass das immer konkret ausgeschalten ist?
Na ja, ein Software Update ist ja per se erstmal nichts Schlechtes.
Ja, es ist nichts Schlechtes, bloß es, wer sagt mir, dass darüber nicht auch irgendwelche Funktionen für den Lächer Benutzer verstanden werden?
Wenn du, wenn, das ist ja eben der Unterschied zur Windows. Wenn du selber Programmierer wärst und den Quellcode lesen könntest, dann könntest du dir selber das durchlesen und könntest dich selbst davon versichern, dass da keine Backgross oder sonst was drin sind. Nachdem du jetzt vielleicht nicht der Freak bist, der da so durchsteigt, gibt es aber immer noch Tausende, wenn nicht Zehntausende bis Hunderttausende weltweit, die das sind und die das lesen. Und sozusagen, wie soll ich sagen, dass dort kein kollektiver Aufschrei erfolgt, kann man davon ausgehen, dass eben keine entsprechenden Lücken vorhanden sind. Bei Windows kann das eben nur eine kleine Gemeinde von Windows-Entwicklern lesen. Und das ist dann das Problem.
Gerade wenn bei Suze wirklich was Dramatisches wäre mit Software-Update, dass da jemand leicht dazwischen gehen kann und es leicht eine Möglichkeit gibt, da irgendwie bösen Code einzuspielen, dann würde es keine 20 Minuten dauern. Und das wäre ein dickes Teil auf heise.de oder sogar auf anderen Nachrichtenkanälen. Also grundsätzlich gilt, Sicherheit ist immer schwierig, aber übermäßige Paranoia hilft einem manchmal auch nicht weiter.
Gut, und dann noch was anderes, was ich nur noch mal anmerken wollte. Ich habe auch mit meinem Windows XP-System, was ich vorher immer hatte, ich hatte einen Router von Teletat und ich hatte so mit Sicherheit oder sowas, was auch so Trojaner und Viren und sowas, hatte ich eigentlich noch nie Probleme gehabt. Ich habe auch immer schön die E-Mail-Software von Microsoft benutzt, dieses Outlook 2000 und ich hatte nie Sorgen mit irgendwas. Ich habe auch öfters mal einen Sicherheitscheck gemacht, da gibt es so eine Seite, da kann man seinen Rechner scannen lassen gegen irgendwelche Eindringe hier, Portscan und all so ein Blödsinn. Habe ich ab und an mal gemacht und sie waren mal sehr sicher betitelt.
Schweingate.
Gut, dann klöpfen wir uns auf die Schulter und sagen danke für den Anruf.
Alles klar, ich bedanke mich auch.
Tschüss, Christian. So, jetzt noch auf die Schnelle, bevor wir den nächsten Schritt machen im Thema der Christian aus Meißen. Hi, Christian. Okay, der Schritt war schnell. Christian, bist du da?
Nee, ich habe noch eine Frage. Also, natürlich nicht ich, sondern ich habe eine Frage aus dem Forum, wo also jemand gefragt hat, ob Firewalls den Downloadraten schaden. Das kann man im allgemeinen guten Gewissens mit Nein beantworten.
Es sei denn, es ist gewünscht.
Ja, das hat aber dann eigentlich mit einer Firewall nichts zu tun, sondern das ist dann eigentlich irgendwie... Es gibt natürlich auch Geräte, die Downloadraten verändern können. Ja, da geht es dann um sogenanntes Traffic Shaping oder Quality of Service oder was auch immer. Hat aber mit einer Firewall eigentlich nichts zu tun. Und egal, ob jetzt Personal Firewalls oder irgendwelche Geräte, die man sich kauft, für die Geschwindigkeiten, mit denen man zu Hause ans Netz angebunden ist, was weiß ich DSL, und selbst wenn es die neue 3-Megabit SuperDUFA-Variante ist, gibt es da keine Schwierigkeiten. Also, seitens ich habe einen Rechner von vor 10 Jahren.
Oder ihr seid bei so einem Provider wie Tiskali, die halt schon providerseitig bestimmte Ports, da sind wir wieder beim Thema, halt runtershapen, also langsam machen, damit eben darüber kein Peer-to-Peer-Networking betrieben wird. Also sowas gibt es halt auch.
Zwei Fragen klären wir noch schnell von Marco aus Belgien.
Hallo Marco.
Du hast einen Router und kannst damit nicht übers Netz spielen.
Genau, also das habe ich bloß durch einen Zufall irgendwie festgestellt, weil ich spiele eigentlich nicht oft. Aber bei einem, also einem Abend, wo ich hier mal spielen wollte mit einem Kumpel, da mussten wir unsere IP-Adressen angeben. Und da habe ich festgestellt, dass das nicht ginge. Und weil ich habe in diesem HomeNet-Kontrollfenster, da habe ich eine IP, eine zugewiesene IP-Adresse und eine zugewiesene DNS-Adresse, da habe ich beides ausprobiert. Und das ging nicht. Und dann hat der Rechner aber auch noch mal eine andere IP-Adresse. Jetzt wollte ich wissen, ob das eventuell daran liegt, dass das halt unterschiedlich ist oder warum auch immer das nicht funktioniert.
Das generelle Problem ist, also das hängt immer davon ab, was das für ein Spiel ist und was für Protokolle wir haben und so weiter. Das generelle Problem, das liegt gar nicht beim Anwender oder bei dem Router oder bei wem auch immer, sondern das Problem sind die Spielerhersteller, beziehungsweise die Entwickler, die die Protokolle entwickeln, mit denen diese Spiele miteinander kommunizieren. Die sitzen immer alle auf einer grünen Wiese und stellen sich vor, die Welt wäre schön und das Internet ist noch zehn Jahre, also das Internet ist noch so, wie es vor zehn Jahren war und es gäbe keine Geräte, die nackt machen im Internet. Die Realität ist aber, dass 90 Prozent der Anwender hinter irgendeinem Router oder hinter einem Gerät sitzen, das eben Network Address Translation betreibt und die Protokolle, die müssen eben speziell so entwickelt sein, dass sie mit dieser Network Address Translation klarkommen. Leider tun die das eben alle nicht und das verursacht dann die Probleme bei den Anwendern daheim zu Hause. Ein Idealrezept gibt es dafür keines, weil das eben immer ganz spezifisch darauf ankommt, was das für ein Spiel ist, wie dieses Protokoll aussieht und da kann man pauschal keine Antwort dazu geben.
Was war es denn für ein Spiel? Nur mal kurz, Marco.
Das war einmal Motocross, Madness und noch irgend so ein Zeug.
Also schon modernere Spiele. Da wird es garantiert irgendeinen How-To Guide geben im Internet, wo jemand schon mal genau das Problem hatte. Einfach mal Router und Dings.
Ich muss nicht unbedingt spielen. Das war halt bloß mal so. Ich habe sonst eigentlich gar keine Probleme mit irgendwelchen Viren oder so. Ich habe auch ein Scanprogramm drauf, hier Art-of-Wear. Das geht eigentlich ganz gut. Und im Norden, das immer auf dem neuesten Stand.
Also bei Spielen gilt leider die Faustregel. Die Zeit muss man sich mitnehmen, wenn man das machen will, dass man damit rechnen kann, dass das passiert. Und da, wie gesagt, guckst du dann einfach jeweils einzeln nach, Marco.
Die DNS-Adresse hat übrigens auch nichts damit zu tun, sondern es ist die Adresse von dem Nameserver, der dann den Namen in numerische IP-Adressen auflöst.
Schönen Abend, schönen Abend noch.
So, wird noch ganz schnell der Sirko aus Dresden und dann geht's weiter. Hallo, Sirko. Moment, ich muss mal eben hier noch mal einen Knopf drücken.
Ich hab so ein ähnliches Problem mit der Kunde, der gerade angerufen hat. Und zwar, ich hab auch ein Router bei mir zu Hause, will denen seine IP feststellen, die mir zugewiesen wird per Internet. Habe dazu schon, bin ich reingekommen, hab dazu das Bali dann mit dem S-Programm installiert und entwickelt und hab dann aber dummerweise bei dem Router irgendwas an dem Port verändert. Und jetzt komm ich in den Router nicht mehr rein. Kann man da irgendwie am XP irgendwas machen, um wieder auf diesen Port zugreifen zu können? Der war vorher 80, ich hab ihn auf 80, 80 gesetzt.
Du hast an deinem Router den Port verändert, oder? Den Administrationsport.
Ja, und selbst mit Routerreset-Taste komm ich nicht mehr rein.
Was für ein Router?
Also normalerweise gibt es bei jedem Router die Möglichkeit, den zu resetten.
Genau, da hängen so ein Reset-Tast dran. Er funktioniert weiter, ich kann weiter auf ihn zugreifen, aber ich komm nicht in die Software des Routers rein.
Also wenn dein Router sich durch die Reset-Taste nicht resetten lässt, dann würde ich das Ding einfach mal zum Händler bringen. Da können wir dir jetzt auch nicht weiterhelfen.
Ansonsten kannst du auch mal im Programm versuchen, was ein Portscan macht, was einfach alle verfügbaren Ports ausprobiert und guckt, was da offen ist auf dem Router.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Und ansonsten würde ich mir die Anleitung mal durchlesen, weil oft man vertauscht einen Reset-Knopf und einfach den Knopf, der den Router einmal an- und ausmacht und den neu hochfährt sozusagen, weil da ja auch ein Betriebssystem drauf ist. Und es gibt oft sowas wie aufschrauben, dann hier einmal den Jumper setzen und so. Das steht dann aber wirklich nur in der Anleitung drin.
Und die einfachste Methode seiner IP-Adresse, also die IP-Adresse, die der Router zugewiesen bekommt, mal daraus zu finden, ist einfach mit einem Webbrowser auf whatismyip.com zu gehen.
Ja, aber dann hab ich ja die IP-Adresse von meinem Rechner ab.
Nein, die vom Router, die mit der du rausgehst.
Die wird ja durch diese NAT maskiert, also maskiert.
whatismyip.com Ganz einfach.
Bitte schön.
Er hat da ein interessantes Thema angesprochen, auf das wir sowieso noch eingehen wollten. Er hat dünn DNS erwähnt. Das ist jetzt konkret der Name eines bestimmten Dienstes, steht aber auch mehr für so ein Konzept, nämlich Dynamic DNS. Das Problem ist ja, haben wir ja schon erwähnt, man bekommt die IP-Adresse vom Provider zugewiesen und man bekommt nicht immer die gleiche, also in der Regel nicht die gleiche IP-Adresse zugewiesen. Das kann zwar sein, muss aber nicht sein. Und wenn man nun selber von zu Hause einen Dienst anbieten möchte, also wenn man von außen, also sprich von irgendwo im Internet auf seine eigenen Rechner zu Hause zugreifen möchte, dann gibt es erstmal zwei Probleme. Das erste ist, woher weiß ich eigentlich welche IP-Adresse gerade mein Computer hat. Und das zweite ist, wie konfiguriere ich mein System, dass durch dieses NAT von außen ein Zugriff auf den Rechner möglich ist, obwohl das ja normalerweise eben nicht so ohne weiteres geht. Diese Dienste, dyndns.org ist einer der populären, da gibt es auch noch diverse weitere. Das funktioniert so, dass man sich dort einen Account macht, sprich Login, Passwort, sich zuteilen lässt. Die sind auch in der Regel kostenlos. Man kann auch was dafür bezahlen, dann kriegt man noch ein bisschen Schnickschnack extra dazu, aber das meiste ist frei. Und was da noch erfordert, ist, dass man auf seinem Computer ein Programm startet, was sich regelmäßig mit diesem zentralen Server verbindet und dort einfach mal ein paar Pakete hinschickt, damit der weiß, zu welchem Account welche IP-Adresse gehört. Und dann hat man eben unter deren Domänen irgendeine Subdomänen, also was weiß ich, chaosradio.dünndns.org und kann eben von außen unter diesem Namen zunächst einmal das eigene Netz erreichen. Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal nur die IP-Adresse von dem eigenen Router und das hilft erstmal nicht weiter. Das, was man jetzt noch benötigt, um wirklich dann auf einen offenen Dienst, auf dem eigenen Rechner zugreifen zu können, ist ein sogenanntes Port Forwarding. Also der Port ist ja der Ort, an dem der Dienst bereitgestellt wird. Aber wenn ich von außen auf diese IP-Adresse zugreife, also auf meine mir zugeteilte IP-Adresse zugreife, dann lande ich ja erstmal nur beim Router. Ich möchte aber, dass es durchgereicht wird. Nun ist das NAT eben dazwischen. Und damit das geht, kann man bei den meisten Geräten ein sogenanntes Port Forwarding einrichten. Das heißt, man konfiguriert fest, wenn dieser Port von außen angesprochen wird, dann reiche das doch bitte durch nach innen auf meinen Computer mit der IP-Adresse sowieso. Und dann kann man dort den Dienst nutzen. Das ist ganz praktisch. Man kann dann halt einen Webserver zu Hause betreiben oder auch auf einen Filesharing-Dienst zugreifen. SMB, AFP, was auch immer man da gerade hat. Bei SMB ist es glaube ich noch ein bisschen trickier, oder?
SMB geht nicht so. Also SMB vielleicht zunächst zur Erklärung ist das Protokoll, das bei Windows-Produkten für die Dateifreigabe, also für das Zugreifen auf Netzwerke, Laufwerke verwendet wird. Und da ist es so, dass das von sich aus durch NAT nicht so hundertprozentig funktioniert. Da braucht man eben auch wieder ein sogenanntes Application Layer Gateway. Aber generell, ganz egal, was für einen Dienst man eben freigeben möchte auf das Internet, ist eben in dem Fall, dass man NAT betreibt, so ein Port Forwarding notwendig. Es wird auch manchmal als sogenanntes Destination NAT bezeichnet, um eben hier den Zugriff zu ermöglichen. Das ganze Problem, könnte man sich fragen, ja wozu brauche ich so einen speziellen Eintrag? Ich habe doch einen Router oder Router, der eben das weiterleiten soll. Das Problem entsteht eben auch wieder daraus, dass wir intern eben andere IP-Adressen haben wie außerhalb und dass überhaupt dieses NAT gemacht werden muss, weil nur eine IP-Adresse vom Provider kommt.
Es gibt auch einige Router, die so dünn-DNS und ähnliche Dienste von sich aus schon unterstützen, wo also der Client, um das zu benutzen, gleich mit eingebaut ist. Weißt du welche? Hier ein Metgear macht das zum Beispiel.
Mein Vaigua macht das auch, da kann ich es direkt eintragen.
Ich denke alle aktuellen Produkte haben das schon.
Jetzt spezifisch DynDNS oder mehrere Dienste?
Die bieten eigentlich meistens sogar noch mehrere an. Also homeip.net zum Beispiel auch noch. Ja, den hier wohl auch. Da werden, ist ja auch so, selbst wenn so ein Router das im Moment nicht hat, dann beim nächsten Firmware Update ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass sowas mit drin ist. Da gibt es ja ständig auch Neues. Firmware ist sozusagen die Software, die in dem Gerät, in diesem Router, oder NAT, oder was auch immer es sein mag, drin läuft. Und die kann man sich dann eben auch beim Hersteller herunterladen. Das ist vielleicht auch noch ein interessanter Punkt, den man hier ansprechen sollte. Wir machen uns die ganze Zeit Gedanken über Sicherheit, sprechen über Firewalls, Router, NAT. Wer sagt mir denn, dass diese Firewall im Router nicht vielleicht auch mal einen Bug hat? Und wie garantiere ich denn die Sicherheit davon? Und das ist auch nicht anders als bei anderer Software. Die kann natürlich auch Fehler haben. Und da gibt es dann eben Updates für die Software auf dieser Firewall auf dem Router. Und da sollte man sich auch immer mal wieder beim Hersteller umschauen, ob es da eben ein Update dafür gibt und das dann entsprechend einspielen. Leider muss man sagen, sind die Hersteller hier sehr nachlässig. Also ich bin da sehr intensiv befasst mit dem Thema. Und es ist also so, dass viele dieser Router Linux einsetzen, was ja an und für sich erfreulich ist. Also man kauft sich hier einen D-Link oder Netgear oder Allnet oder Linksys-Router. Und dann ist da tatsächlich ein Linux-System drauf mit einer Linux-Firewall. Ist ja schön. Nur hat die halt auch manchmal vielleicht ein Sicherheitsloch. Und dann sind diese Hersteller leider nicht immer so ihren Kunden angetan und bieten daran tatsächlich ein Update für dieses Sicherheitsloch an. Das ist also ein bisschen nachlässig hier, die Hersteller in dem Punkt.
Gibt es da jemanden, dem man besonders hervorheben kann, dass er regelmäßig Updates liefert?
Ich glaube am positivsten ist hier die Firma Linksys zu nennen. Die ersten waren, die einen Linux-basierten Router auch für WLAN Netze und so weiter angeboten haben. Das ist der gute alte VAT54G. Und die haben da am meisten Erfahrung, die machen das lang genug. Und die wissen auch, dass Linux drin ist. Viele der angeblichen Hersteller wissen ja gar nicht, dass sie da Linux verbauen in den Geräten, weil das irgendeine Klitsche in Taiwan macht und dann nur der Name Fujitsu Siemens drauf gedruckt wird oder was auch immer.
Und feiern dann aus allen Wolken, wenn da plötzlich jemand kommt und sagt, er würde gerne mal den source code sehen, weil Linux steht ja unter so einer Lizenz, wo man dann auch den source code weitergeben muss.
Genau, also da passiert leider viel, was nicht so ganz so schön ist. Das einzige, was ich hier an den Punkt anbringen wollte, ist auch die Firmware, die auf dem Router läuft, kann Sicherheitslöcher haben und man sollte sich immer mal nach den Updates umgucken.
Du hast da ja ein paar Analysen betrieben, was die spezifischen Router betrifft und welche Software sie einsetzen.
Ja, das ist in der Tat richtig. Nachdem ich eben einer der Urheber von dieser IP-Tables-Software, also dem Firewalling-System von Linux bin, habe ich mir sehr viele dieser Router angesehen. Die Firmware, die da drauf ist und so nach den Analysen, die ich betrieben habe, kann ich sagen, ungefähr 30% dieser Geräte basieren eben auf Linux. Also schon ganz enorm. Wenn man sich anguckt in was für Stückzahlen, die verkauft werden, bei Media Markt, bei sonst irgendwo. Also es ist so, dass wahrscheinlich 10.000 von mindestens Menschen in Deutschland Linux daheim haben, aber gar nichts davon wissen, weil es einfach auf so einem Router ist und nur irgendwo drauf steht, dass Linux drin ist.
Gibt es da eigentlich eine Webseite irgendwie zu nehmen? Da gab es doch dieses Lizenzüberprüfungs...
Ja, eine Webseite, also ich habe angefangen, eine Webseite zu machen, die heißt gplviolations.org, also gplviolations.org. Das ist im Moment noch ein bisschen im Aufbau begriffen, aber da versuche ich immer so ein bisschen den Stand der Dinge zu dokumentieren. Es ist aber wirklich so, dass egal, welchen Hersteller man sich anschaut, egal ob Siemens, Fujitsu Siemens, D-Link, Allnet, Belkin, Netgear, wen habe ich denn vergessen, Sitecom...
Boardcom macht nur Design, ne?
Boardcom macht nur die Chips, ja. Aber jeden namhaften Hersteller von solchen Geräten, da findet man, US Robotics habe ich vergessen, da findet man mindestens eines oder mehrere Produkte, in denen eben Linux zum Einsatz kommt. Und ja, ich bin etwas dabei, dafür zu sorgen, dass die auch den Quellcode entsprechend...
Also wer da Lust hat, auf ein bisschen genauer reinzuschauen, ein bisschen basteln, dem sei die letzte oder vorletzte Ausgabe der Computerzeitschrift CT empfohlen. Die haben sich nämlich diesen Linksys-Router mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut, haben das das Linux analysiert und geben aus eine kleine Anleitung, wie man da ein eigenes System raufpacken kann, was denn entsprechend seinen Bedürfnissen zusammengestrickt ist.
Genau, das ist nämlich, also diese, diese, diese... Ich sag ja auch schon die ganze Zeit Router, in Wirklichkeit sind es ja eigentlich Gateways, die unter anderem Routing, NAT und Firewall Funktionen anbieten. Aber diese Geräte eben, die sind ja so wahnsinnig günstig, also mittlerweile für 50, 60 Euro teilweise. Für 100 Euro kriegt man echt ein ganz tolles Gerät schon mittlerweile. Und gut, das kann jetzt vielleicht drei, vier Funktionen. Ich möchte aber noch andere haben. Und es ist ja Linux drauf. Und wenn ich mich entsprechend mit dem Gerät auseinandersetze, dann kann ich da eben auch andere Dinge drauf installieren. Und es ist viel stromsparender, viel kleiner, macht keinen Lärm, als da jetzt irgendwie noch ein extra PC dafür hinzuwenden.
Was könnte man da noch draufpacken?
Na, es gibt Leute, die zumindest schon mal zu aller Anfang irgendwie SSH drauf installieren. Dann können sie sich erstmal drauf einloggen auf dem System. Dann kannst du da im Prinzip irgendwie eigene Webseiten zum Beispiel drauflegen. Du kannst Dinge, zum Beispiel jetzt in Quality of Service ist so ein Stichpunkt, wo man die Bandbreite versucht, irgendwie sinnvoll zu verteilen und nicht zufällig, dass man eben trotz, dass man gerade einen riesen Download macht, immer noch mit akzeptabler Pingzeit spielen kann oder Voice-over-IP machen kann. Was auch immer, solche Funktionen kann man da eben noch mit draufpacken, die es im Fertigprodukt so noch nicht gibt. Da gibt es mittlerweile auch ganze Distributionen, zum Beispiel das Projekt Open VRT. Das also hier, VRT bezieht sich auf dieses Cisco, Entschuldigung, Linksys Produkt, das ich vorhin genannt hatte, dieser Linksys VRT54G. Da kann ich also die Originalfirmware vom Hersteller runterschmeißen und kann eben einfach dieses Open VRT installieren und das bietet mir dann eben mehr Funktionen. Also da gibt es eine regelrechte Community mittlerweile für diese Geräte, die also alternative Firmware eben anbietet.
Was sind denn da eigentlich für Prozessoren drauf auf diesen Geräten?
In den Linksys und auch Belkin und den weitverbreitetsten Geräten ist es Broadcom MIPS basierend, also es sind 32-bit embedded MIPS, meistens mit so 8 oder 16 MB Flash und 32 oder 64 MB RAM, also kann man schon was damit anstellen. Jaja, da kann man richtig was damit anstellen. Was mittlerweile auch aufkommt, sind ARM-basierte Embedded-Prozessoren oder auch Intel X-Scale, also diese EXP425, für die Leute, die da wirklich in der Teil drin stecken.
Das ist diese ARM-Nachfolger, ne?
Also vielleicht sollten wir nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass es wirklich eine Menge Produkte, nicht Produkte, sondern Projekte gibt, auf Linux-Basis oder wahrscheinlich auch auf BSD-Basis, die auf einer Diskette kommen oder vielleicht auch als CD-Image kommen, die ihr in einen alten, eigentlich ausrangigierten PC reinstecken könnt. Da baut ihr irgendwie zwei Netzwerkkarten ein, eine rein, eine raus und habt da eine wunderbare Firewall, möglicherweise auch noch ein Proxy-Name-Server, möglicherweise auch noch ein Mail-Server, wenn ihr das braucht. Da gibt es also eine ganze Menge Sachen. Macht jetzt keinen Sinn, die alle aufzuzählen. Das sind bestimmt 20, 50, vielleicht sogar 100 Projekte.
Und dann ist es auch nicht so.
Fliefer-Linux genau. Das ist eins der ersten oder wichtigsten vermutlich, wenn es darum geht, per ISDN einen Rechner anzuschließen. Das war das erste Plug-and-Play-Projekt, was ich so kenne.
Uti, 0373-7797-110 ist unsere Nummer. Und ihr könnt zum Thema Firewalls auch noch anrufen und Fragen stellen oder vielleicht eure Erlebnisse schildern. Hier hat das Chaosradio auf. Fritz, eine gute Stunde haben wir noch. Frank, Harald, Tim und Max hier sitzenderweise vor dem Mikrofon. Und der Andreas aus Fürstenwalde ist am Telefon. Hallo Andreas.
Hallöchen.
Telefon erst mal umstellen, Lautsprecher ausschalten. Und zwar hab ich eigentlich zwei Sachen. Und zwar einmal ein Erlebnis und einmal eine Frage.
Und zwar einmal ein Erlebnis.
Meine Frau suchte so, weil wir Nachrufserfahrten nach einem Kindernamen und ging dann so auf diese Seite www.vornamen.de. Drückte dann, ja, hier gibt es Vornamen und drücken sie doch bitte hier rauf. Es installierte sich ein Teiler. Und ich war glücklicher Besitzer oder bin zum Glück immer noch glücklicher Besitz einer Fritzkart mit diesem ISDN Monitor, mit dieser Rufnummernüberwachung, die mich dann vor dieser berühmten Hamburger Inkassofirma gerettet hat. Eine sehr schöne Sache finde ich. Ja, es hat zwar nicht so richtig mit dem Firewall zu tun, aber so diese Rufnummernüberwachung und ja, in der Zwischenzeit habe ich auch DSL rausziehen der ISDN-Leitung aus der Karte, aus dem Rechner ist so irgendwie bei mir entstand geworden. Ich denke mal, da gibt es auch bei euch ein paar gute Erfahrungen, die in den Vorwarnungen unterrichtet worden sind.
Wenn ich da vielleicht an der Stelle gleich wieder erwähnen darf, dass in dem Fall ein Router tatsächlich hilft. Es gibt auch Router für ISDN, die sind auch nicht teurer als die für DSL. Da steckt man eben dann dieses ISDN-Kabel rein, statt Indikate im Rechner, verbindet dann übers Netzwerk den VC mit diesem Router und schon ist man allen Dialern der Welt ausgewichen. Weil dann eben egal, was dieser Dialer irgendwie versucht zu tun auf deinem Windows-Rechner, das interessiert diesen Router überhaupt gar nicht.
Ja, hast du schon recht, hatte ich auch mal so ein Teil. So gab man so die erste Teile, so dieses iGate von Siemens, so ein wireless LAN-ISDN-Router. Der steht hier irgendwie das lange im Dachboden so als, weiß nicht, Anstaubungsobjekt. Kann man irgendwie zu gar nichts benutzen. Die wireless LAN-Karte ist noch ganz gut. Das Problem, was ich nämlich hatte mit diesem Router, war, dass ich einmal zur Firma rauswählen wollte und einmal natürlich auch so normal ins Internet. Und wenn man dann halt ein wunderschönes Windows auf seinem Rechner hat, dann hat man also irgendwie alle drei Minuten so einen Verbindungsaufbau mit ISDN drauf, was nun nicht so ideal war, wenn man es bezahlen muss halt, die Verbindung.
Ja gut, das kommt dann auf das Gerät an, was man da kauft. Diese Siemens iGate, die waren, glaube ich, eine der ersten, die das angeboten haben. Da war das auch noch nicht so weit. Aber in der Regel kann man auf den zumindest etwas besseren Geräten dann auch konfigurieren, dass man sagt, ja, wenn dies oder jenes passiert, dann wird eine Verbindung aufgebaut. Oder man schaltet dieses automatische Wellen überhaupt komplett ab und man muss dann erstmal auf eine Webseite auf diesem ISDN-Router gehen und da irgendwie auf einen Knopf drauf klicken und dann wird eben die Verbindung aufgebaut. Und irgendwann klicke ich wieder auf den Knopf und die Verbindung wird abgebaut. Gibt es also schon auch.
Mein DSL-Router hat übrigens sogar noch das Feature, dass ich mir das Paket anzeigen lassen kann, analysieren lassen kann, welches eine Verbindung aufgebaut hätte.
Na ja, so gut ist mein Router nur auch nicht und dieser Sieb ins Eigelb, das war so vor drei Jahren so der erste Versuch.
Eben, eben, eben.
Mensch, sag ich mal, für, was war das damals? 58 Mark, so im Ausverkauf dachte, Mensch, da nimmst du die mit. Also, so will ich, kommst du nie wieder an so eine PCMCIA-Karte ran. Die Karte ist ganz gut, also irgendwann habe ich es auch hingekriegt mit irgendwelcher Verschlüsselung, weil mit diesem neueren Verschlüsselungssystem wurde die auch nicht so richtig, aber naja. Eine Geschichte, so zweite Geschichte ist, hier hatte ich jetzt gerade so ein schönes Thema angeschnitten, nämlich so Router und so Firewall und Sicherheit und gerade diese ganze DynDNS-Service. Ich besuche auch so einen Router, so einen SMC-Router, habe auch so eine wunderschöne DynDNS-Adresse bekommen, klappt auch wunderbar, er verbindet sich dahin, Adresse wird aktualisiert. Nur ist das Problem, ich möchte eigentlich auf meinen Rechner so von außen einfach so, ich sag mal ganz profan, der FDP einfach mal zugreifen. Wenn ich jetzt allerdings so einen FDP-Port aufreiße, ist mir der doch ein bisschen zu weit offen. Also wenn ich das jetzt in der Firewall einstelle, also gut, falls etwas von außen kommt, bitte leite das mal auf diesen Port hier weiter. Was gibt es denn da eigentlich jetzt noch, sei mal, für Möglichkeiten, die man einsetzen kann, um, sag ich mal, irgendwie die Sache zu verschlüsseln oder zu verstecken oder...
Also FDP ist... Ja, FDP ist grundsätzlich eigentlich nicht mehr so die Wahl. Also das sollte man echt nur in einem internen Netzwerk verwenden, wo kein Internet dazwischen ist. Also gerade, wenn man von außen zugreift, muss ja einfach bewusst sein, dass bei FDP Passwörter generell unverschlüsselt sind. Ja, okay, aber ist ja eine berechtigte Frage. Es gibt auch Alternativen. Basierend auf diesen SSH-Protokollen gibt es zum Beispiel auch SFTP. Das ist dann halt verschlüsseltes FDP, was auch diverse andere Nachteile von FDP nicht hat, weil es jetzt so mit dem Verbindungsaufbau alles so ein bisschen VUDO und das gehört auch noch zu diesen Protokollen, die so mit dem heutigen weit verbreiteten NAT einfach nicht gut zusammenarbeiten. Aber SFTP ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Ansatz. Da gibt es auf jeden Fall auch Server für.
Dann eben, ja, SCP gibt es eben auch bei dem SSH noch. Es gibt auch, wenn man bei FDP bleibt, gibt es mittlerweile FDP mit SSL, wo also dann eben die Passwortübertragung, auch die Datenübertragung über diesen SSL-Mechanismus gesichert wird. Generell ist FDP aber tatsächlich wirklich nur dort weit verbreitet, wo es um sowieso frei zugängliche Daten in Form von Anonymous FDP gibt.
Was du aber machen kannst, wenn du auf die Daten nur von einem bestimmten Rechner, zum Beispiel bei dir aus der Firma, auszugreifen willst, dann kannst du in der Firewall so einstellen, dass nur aus diesem Netzwerk, wo du dann bist, Verbindungen angenommen werden.
Das Problem ist natürlich, wenn ich jetzt über meinen Provider reingehe, dann kriege ich da irgendwie ein Klaus A Netzwerk, da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, eine 80, 225 Adresse und wenn ich dazu irgendwie weitergehen möchte, ja, das ist ein ziemlich großer Adressbereich von Servern, die da irgendwie drauf zugreifen können.
Moment, also es geht dir darum, du willst ja von irgendwo, von unterwegs zugreifen auf den Rechner, ne? Genau. Und die Frage ist, ob du von überall drauf zugreifen willst oder nur von einem bestimmten Rechner, zum Beispiel von dir von der Firma aus?
Das würde noch gehen, sage ich jetzt mal. Nee, aber es geht wirklich aus dem Internet, sage ich mal. Ich bin jetzt irgendwo jetzt unterwegs, sage ich irgendwo im Internet, sage ich, Mensch, da ist zum Beispiel eine Datei oder irgendwie was, da möchte ich jetzt drauf zugreifen, liegt da und da und dem und dem oder dem verzeichnet, weiß ich, wie komme ich irgendwie halbwegs sicher an meinen Rechner an, ohne dass ich die Kiste jetzt so...
Naja, was man machen könnte, ist ein Web-Server mit SSL. Also du könntest dir auf deinem Rechner einen Web-Server installieren. Also du kannst dir bei HTTP genauso Dateien übertragen. Einen Web-Server mit SSL. Und da erzeugst du dir ein Zertifikat und jedes Mal, wenn du dich darauf verbindest, von irgendwo aus, dann guckst du dir halt, ob dieses Zertifikat stimmt und meldest dich mit Benutzernahme und Passwort an. Und dann ist das eine sichere, verschlüsselte Verbindung. Und du kannst dann die Dateien unterladen.
Die Gefahr oder die Angst, die ich da eigentlich bei habe, ist, sobald ich da irgendwie so ein Port aufmache, sage ich erst mal HTTPS-Ports über den Router zu dem Server, dass dann so von außen, so sage ich mal, mit Portscans und so weiter, ist der Porte erstmal offen, dass da es dann irgendwie weitergeht oder irgendwelche, sag ich mal, nicht das letzte Security-Update und bei dem Standard-Admin...
Das Problem hast du natürlich immer. Wenn du den Dienst anbietest, dann muss es offen sein und dann hast du alle Probleme, die mit der eingesetzten Software mit daherkommen. Da ist dann halt die Frage, was ist der Server, den du benutzt? Wenn du an der Stelle ein Open Source Projekt benutzt, bist du da schon mal nicht schlecht bedient, sagen wir es mal so. Also wenn du dir so einen Apache installierst, zum Beispiel, es gibt auch Web-Server, die jetzt nicht den vollen Funktionsumfang haben, so Tiny. Boa, kenne ich nicht. Aber es gibt also diverse Open Source Mini-Web-Server, die auch in der Lage sind, HTTPS zu machen, womit du das hast. Oder eben auch dieses von mir schon erwähnte SFTP, nur dass diese Clients halt nicht so verbreitet sind. Also nicht jeder Computer, an den du jetzt irgendwie rangehst, dürfte automatisch einen SFTP Client haben. Was schade ist, aber so ist das nun mal. Und beim Webbrowser ist es natürlich, die sind halt verbreitet und HTTPS können sie alle.
Gut, muss ich dann, das ist nochmal eine ganz spezielle Frage, muss ich dann dem Router einfach jetzt bloß sagen, ok, pass mal auf, der Port ist jetzt frei für den Rechner und wenn nicht, oder lohnt sich dann noch irgendwie was einstellen für diese ganze berühmte DMZ und so weiter. Da gab es auch eine Zithese im Brückenartikel, also sprich, einen Rechner davor setzen und sagen, ok, das ist jetzt der eigentliche Rechner und über den gehe ich nur weiter, oder?
Also DMZ können wir ja gleich nochmal extra erklären, aber wichtig ist, dass du die interne Adresse, also die interne IP-Adresse und den internen Port angeben musst. Also der Port, der durch dieses Port Forwarding nach außen geöffnet wird, muss nicht zwangsweise auf dem internen Rechner der gleiche sein. Also du kannst zum Beispiel internen Port 8000 haben und gibts ihn aber nach außen hin als Port 80 frei. Und er wird dann entsprechend die Verbindung weitergeleitet. Von Port 80 auf dem Router auf Port 8000 auf deinem 192.168 irgendwas.
Gut, dann wollen wir mal ausprobieren und mal gucken, was dann noch von dem Rechner übrig bleibt.
So, der Sebastian aus Berlin.
Wollen wir das kurz erklären mit der DMZ?
Ich hätte sonst weitergearbeitet. Sebastian, noch ein Sekündchen, ne?
Na, ist eigentlich auch schnell erklärt. Also DMZ ist halt auch so ein Basswort, steht für Demilitarized Zone und ist eher so ein Konzept.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt immer davon gesprochen, dass so eine Firewall 2 Netzwerkinterfaces hat, ein externes, ein internes und DMZ heißt eben, ich füge da noch ein paar mehr dazu, in der Regel erst mal eins.
Ja, so ist es. Nee, erzähl mal weiter, okay.
Ja, gut und ich hab eben dann sozusagen einmal mein internes Netzwerk, wo meine Clients drinstehen, die PCs, dann hab ich das externe Netzwerk, das ist das Internet und dann hab ich eben noch die DMZ, wo Server stehen, die Dienste nach außen anbieten.
Also die ganz paranoide Variante davon ist eigentlich, dass man zwei Firewalls hat, nämlich die erste nach hinten zum Internet und die zweite nach innen dann zum eigentlichen Netzwerk und da zwischendrin stehen dann die Server.
Es ist so, als würde ich in meine Wohnung gehen, von innen zuschließen, dann in die Küche gehen und die Küche auch nochmal zuschließen, bevor ich mir meine Toast mache, oder?
Genau, dann ist der Flur die demilitarisierte Zone.
Also da muss man halt sehen, ob man genug Computer hat, um das überhaupt zu realisieren, aber für die Vollparanoiden ist gut. Noch ein Tipp zu dem Apache, was ich vorhin meinte, wenn man den installieren will, da gibt es eine schöne Seite, die kannte ich auch noch nicht, bin ich hier gerade drauf hingewiesen worden, im Chat apachefriends.org, gibt es auch in Deutsch, und da wird viel erläutert, wie man sich das leicht installieren kann, auch unter Windows.
Supi, sind wir soweit?
Ja, einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Abend.
Ich hab auch gleich mal eine Frage zum Thema DMZ-Unterstützung von Firewalls und auch VPL-Unterstützung von Firewalls. Und zwar ist mir noch nicht ganz klar der Sinn der Sache jetzt von DMZ. Es ist ja nicht so, das sagen wir mal, es erfolgt jetzt ein Angriff auf einen Server, der in diesem DMZ sich befindet. Und man hat dann Zugriff auf alle anderen Server, die auch in diesem DMZ sich befinden, aber halt keinen Zugriff auf interne Netzwerke.
Richtig, das ist die Hauptidee.
Alles klar. Dann eine andere Frage, die eigentlich in eine ähnliche Richtung geht, und zwar, wenn man jetzt eine Firewall auf dem Lieblingsrechner betreibt, eine Software Firewall, ist es ja eigentlich relativ unsinnig, auf dem gleichen Rechner dann auch zum Beispiel Webserver, Mailserver, DNS laufen zu lassen? Schon, gell?
Na ja, das ist jetzt wieder so eine sicherheitsphilosophische Frage. Generell würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass da Bedenken dagegen sprechen. Du kannst ja problemlos auch auf der Maschine laufende Dienste Paketfilterregeln angeben. Interessant wird es natürlich dann, wenn du sagst, was passiert, wenn da jetzt auf meiner Firewall noch ein Webserver läuft, dieser Webserver eine Sicherheitslücke hat, über diese Sicherheitslücke ein Angreifer Systemadministratorrechte bekommt und dann meine Firewall umkonfigurieren kann. Das ist so das Worst Case Szenario. Und da, wenn man sich da dagegen schützen will, dann nimmt man eben tatsächlich eine dedizierte Firewall, wo nichts anderes läuft als dieser Paketfilter, wo überhaupt gar keine Dienste nach außen hin offen sind, wo überhaupt nichts zugänglich ist. Und dann kann ich mir da sehr sicher sein. Wenn ich noch paranoider sein will, für die Leute, die aus der technischen Ecke kommen, gibt es da noch sogenannte Bridged Firewalls. Das ist dann ein Paketfilter, der gar nicht mehr rootet, sondern der sozusagen nach außen hin wie ein Stück Draht aussieht, das bestimmte Pakete abfängt und ignoriert und andere durchlässt. Das ist dann die super paranoide Version.
Alles klar, mir ging es einfach nur darum, dass man durch diese Möglichkeit die Kosten für so eine DMZ-Erweiterung einspart, indem sowieso diese Dienste, die ich in die DMZ auslangen würde, auf diesem Firewall-Server laufen lasse. Aber wie ihr schon gesagt habt, ist dann die Gefahr, dass dann wieder irgendwelche Fehler in den Diensten da aufkreten, die dann quasi die ganze Firewall-Alarm legen kann.
Richtig, ja. Also ich denke, das mit den Kosten, zumindest bei den Bandbreiten, die man so üblicherweise daheim hat oder auch in kleineren Firmen, kann man einfach dadurch begrenzt halten, dass man sich irgendwie so ein 60 bis 80 Euro, was auch immer, Firewall von Linksys, SMC und Konsorten kauft. Am besten eine, wo man im Netz irgendwie schon gefunden hat, dass es andere Linux-Distributionen dafür gibt. Und dann kann ich da irgendwie konfigurieren, was ich will, wie auf einem anderen Linux-PC. Nur ich hab eben so ein kleines hübsches Kästchen, das braucht wenig Strom, macht keinen Lärm, erzeugt kaum Wärme und kostet ganz wenig Geld. Ich muss keine 1000 Euro für den Rechner ausgeben.
Deine Frage zum Thema VPN, Virtual Private Network, und zwar sieht man ja oft irgendwo Firewalls, bei denen halt steht, von wegen VPN unterstützt. Könnt ihr mir mal kurz erklären, was das eigentlich genau bedeutet, was die Firewall macht, um dieses VPN möglich zu machen?
Da gibt's jetzt wieder die Frage, was das ist.
Also wir werden jetzt mal erklären, was ein VPN ist.
Genau, fangen wir an der Stelle an. VPN steht für Virtual Private Network, also ein virtuelles privates Netzwerk. Was man da macht, ist sozusagen über das Internet ein anderes Netz zu erstellen. Dazu bedient man sich sogenannter Tunnel. Und statt dass, zum Beispiel, wenn man sich eine Firma ansieht, die hat eine Filiale in München und eine in Berlin, die möchte jetzt keine teure Standleitung zwischen München und Berlin betreiben, sondern sie möchte einfach eine sichere Verbindung über das Internet, die aussieht wie ein Netzwerk. Und dann bedient man sich eines solchen VPNs zwischen Berlin und München. Da werden sozusagen die ganzen Pakete in München eingepackt, durch den Tunnel geschickt und fallen dann in Berlin wieder aus dem Tunnel heraus und werden ausgepackt. Ich füge also nochmal einen Umschlag außen herum hinzu um mein Paket und verschlüssel das dann auch dementsprechend, dass also niemand mehr den Inhalt herausfinden kann oder was da tatsächlich der Fall war. Also der Sinn eines Virtual Private Networks. Und was das jetzt mit Firewalls zu tun hat, gut, das gibt da zweierlei Punkte. Zum einen kann ich Firewalls oder eben, jetzt wieder die Frage, ist das eine Firewall? Also ich kann solche Geräte, auf denen auch eine Firewall implementiert wird, kann ich dazu verwenden ein Ende eines solchen Tunnels herzustellen. Also ich kann zum Beispiel das Gerät hier in Berlin, das kann eine Firewall sein, die eben auch gleichzeitig so einen VPN-Tunnel beschickt von einer Seite. Oder aber ich kann eine Firewall haben oder ein NAT insbesondere, dass es erlaubt, solche VPN-Tunnel durch dieses NAT hindurch zu betreiben. Das ist also dann eben die Unterstützung dafür, VPN zu NATen. Nein, so einfach ist es leider nicht. Also diese VPN-Protokolle sind in der Regel sehr komplex und bedienen sich da mehrere Verbindungen und vor allem Protokollen, die sonst nicht im Netz üblich sind. Und deswegen ist es etwas komplexer an der Stelle. Auch in Bezug auf die Sicherheit macht man da natürlich sehr viel größere Umstände als bei einer einfachen HTTP-Verbindung. Und deswegen sind das nicht nur ein Port, sondern das sind gleich mehrere und die müssen in bestimmten Verhältnissen zueinander stehen.
Also VPN ist vor allem auch erstmal ein Buzzword und die eigentlichen Protokolle, die man sozusagen VPN zuordnet, haben nochmal andere Namen. Sehr verbreitet ist PPTP, also Point-to-Point Tunneling-Protokoll. Das kommt glaube ich aus der Microsoft-Welt ein wenig. Und bedient sich auch noch eines weiteren Cisco-Protokolls.
Nämlich dem GRE.
Was dann auch auf sehr niedriger Ebene spielt. Das heißt, es kann sehr wohl sein, dass eure Router oder Firewalls überhaupt den Betrieb von PPTP verhindern, wenn sie nicht richtig gut arbeiten. Dann gibt es noch das L2TP mit IPSEC.
Das ist schon die Paranoid-Aviation.
Nein, es gibt erst mal allein das L2TP, das Layer-2-Tunneling-Protokoll. Dann gibt es eben noch IPSEC, IPsecurity. Und dann kann ich noch L2TP mit IPSEC kombinieren. Das ist dann wieder was, was Microsoft ganz gern tut. Und dann gibt es noch eine ganze Reihe weiterer Protokolle. Deswegen ist VPN oder VPN-Funktionalität eines Routers so vage definiert, wie es nur irgendwie geht. Also man muss schon ganz konkret wissen, worum es geht und was ich habe.
Es gibt aber auch ein Open-Source-Projekt, das nennt sich OpenVPN.
Es gibt OpenVPN, es gibt VITAN, es gibt CYPE, es gibt, was habe ich jetzt noch vergessen? Also es gibt...
Eine VIE, einiges.
Und zu Risiken und Nebenwirkungen fragen sie ihren Systemadministranten.
Gibt es noch irgendeine Seite, wo man da mal als Sprungseite draufgehen kann? Vielleicht für Sebastian jetzt, weil wir können jetzt nicht...
Es gibt die Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia zu dieser Radiosendung. Da wird das gerade alles fleißig eingetragen. Das hoffe ich zumindest, muss gleich noch mal nachschauen. Aber auch im Chat hier im IRCP...
Da ist übrigens auch ein Link zur Aussprache der Router oder Router von leo.org. Das muss ich einfach anhören. Das müssen wir irgendwie, das muss ich jetzt hier gleich mal, weil ich will es wissen.
Naja, das ist immer wieder der Complaint Nummer 1, ob man denn nun Router oder Router sagt im Kern, das ist eigentlich egal.
Das stand auch schon bei uns auf der Webseite, auf fritz.de.
Ja, das Thema haben wir auch schon andere Rufe in vorhergehenden Sendungen erwähnt.
Genau, es ist eine Never-Ending-Story.
Noch eine Frage, wenn es zulässig ist, und zwar, angenommen, ich habe ein internes Netzwerk, was jetzt über Firewall per Standleitung und Internet angeschlossen ist, und ich habe hier Möglichkeit, jetzt über relativ viele feste IP-Adressen zu verfügen, wäre es sicherheitstechnisch cleverer, trotzdem die internen Rechner über NAT laufen zu lassen, oder kann man genauso gut auch die ganzen internen Rechner, weil man immer so viele feste IP-Adressen hat, auch denen einfach eine feste IP geben?
Also für die Sicherheit ist das in Grunde nicht relevant. Du kannst problemlos, das nennen wir das, weil die Leute behaupten irgendwie, ich mache NAT und das ist dann sicher. Sicher ist das nicht.
Na, das kann auf jeden Fall von draußen nicht erreicht werden.
Das ist auch noch nicht der Fall, wenn du ein 1 zu 1 NAT machst, also dass einer internen Adresse eindeutig eine externe Adresse zugeordnet wird. Du machst das für alle deine Rechner. Dann macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob du dir eine offizielle Adresse gibst oder ob du so ein 1 zu 1 NAT machst.
Das Konzept verstehe ich auch bis heute nicht. Ich habe das auch schon in mehreren Firmen erlebt und das ist irgendwie ganz komisch.
Also im Grunde kann man sagen, technologisch gibt es da keinen Unterschied vom Sicherheitslevel her. Es ist nur vielleicht für den Netzwerkadministrator irgendwie auffälliger, wenn irgendwo ein Problem besteht, wenn er dann im Internet ein Netz auf einmal sieht, Pakete mit offiziellen Adressen oder stimmt irgendwas nicht oder wie auch immer. Aber technisch ist das Irrelevanz, mag psychologisch was ausmachen.
Ja, wenn du die IP-Adressen wirklich über hast, ist es sicherlich kein Problem zu benutzen, aber man muss sich schon darüber im Klaren... Also wenn du jetzt wirklich nur so ein Terminal hast, wo eh nur web geklickt wird oder ein bisschen Mail gemacht wird, dann kann man das beruhigt auch hinter einen NAT packen und spart sich schon mal die IP-Adressen, wenn man jetzt nicht so viel hat. Aber wenn du da aus dem Vollen schöpfen kannst, na Gott, dann schöpf aus dem Vollen. Also es gibt halt auch Anwendungen, die profitieren schon sehr davon, wenn man keinen NAT hat. Das gilt insbesondere für Telefonie-Software, Voice-over-IP oder eben auch Videokonferenzen. Das ist ja mittlerweile recht populär, nicht zu unrecht, weil man damit eine ganze Menge Geld sparen kann. Das sind Protokolle, die sehr häufig erstmal Peer-to-Peer-Verbindungen machen, auf nicht gewöhnlichen Ports, dazu auch noch UDP benutzen. Und da gibt es mit NAT schon immer eine Menge Stress. Und wenn man den von vornherein vermeiden möchte, dann ist man natürlich mit einer richtigen IP-Adresse ganz gut bedient.
Würdet ihr euch noch zu einer Empfehlung hinreißen lassen, letzten Endes, was ist unter Kosten, Gesichtspunkten, die klärfeste Lösung wäre, wenn man jetzt eine Firewall haben will, inklusive Routerfunktion, NAT, Paketfilter, demlitalisierte Zone und VPN?
Nee, das musst du selber rausfieben.
Nee, da würde ich jetzt auch einfach nichts dazu sagen. Das kommt wirklich immer sehr drauf an, auf das Szenario, welche Bandbreiten usw. Außerdem würden wir dann hier jetzt letztendlich irgendwie Werbung machen für einen bestimmten Anbieter.
Ja, aber wir haben durchaus einen...
Du wirst keine Hardware Firewall finden, weil die Hardware Firewall hat auch Software drauf, die es letztendlich wieder macht.
Software ist immer Software. Also wenn da irgendwas tut, dann ist es Software. Und wie gesagt, unsere Auffassung nach ist es generell gut, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, dass man sich den Code, der da läuft, auch anschauen kann. Das gilt für alle die Router, die halt Linux einsetzen und wo die Firmen auch... Ja oder auch BSD, aber BSD ist im Embedded Bereich einfach nicht so verbreitet. Die meisten nehmen schon...
Doch, aber du kannst den Quellcode halt nicht einsehen.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Weil bei BSD müsste er herstellen.
Du kannst ihn dann nicht einsehen, wenn sie ihn nicht freilegen. Also bei Linux ist es quasi Pflicht, dass er eingesehen wird, weil das eben die GPL-Lizenz ist, die das erfordert. Bei BSD kann das getan werden. Und es gibt halt zahlreiche Router. Wir haben sie ja vorhin schon aufgezählt, die eben das machen, die Firmware-Updates liefern. Und es gibt eben dann auch diese begleitenden Projekte wie OpenWrt. Dort würde ich einfach mal schauen, ob es nicht vielleicht fertige Konfigurationen gibt, die da deinen Ansprüchen genügen.
Ich nehme mal an, das ist jetzt eher irgendwie ein Firmenumfeld oder ein professionelles Umfeld, wenn es also um viele IP-Adressen und so geht. Da gibt es durchaus auch kommerzielle Anbieter, die Linux oder Open Source basierte Lösungen anbieten. Wo man sich jetzt aber nicht mit der ganzen Konfiguration auseinandersetzen muss, da kann man vielleicht mal irgendwie nennen Firmen wie Smoothwall oder was gibt es denn sonst noch? Gate Protect, SecurePoint, Astaro und dergleichen. Also da gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Firmen, die dir quasi Linux basierte Lösungen anbieten mit Clicky Bunti, Webfrontend.
Da findest du auch auf der Wiki Seite schon diverse URLs und vielleicht sogar noch mehr, als ich hier gerade auf meinem V4 stehen hab.
Ist dir eigentlich auch bei OS X Server 10.2.8 die Firewall, die du integriert hast, auch IP-Tables basiert?
Nein, weil das nicht Linux ist, sondern das ist ja Darwin, was weitgehend BSD basiert ist. Das benutzt eben das BSD-Firewall-System, IPFW. Genau. Wobei, da würde ich dir durchaus zu einem Upgrade auf 10.3. Server raten.
Ja, das kostet leider bei Apple ja nicht gerade.
Ok, Sebastian, schönen Schlaf noch. Also zum Thema Router-Router. Ich bin jetzt auch mal den Link gefolgt. Und das Lustige ist, dass wir dann zum Merriam Webstars Online Dictionary kommen, die uns sagen, es gibt dreimal das Nomen Router oder Router. Bei Nummer 1 steht das heißt Router und da steht drunter One That Routes. Und dann klickt man auf Nomen Nummer 2, da steht Router One That Routes. Alles klar, also wir wissen mittlerweile mehr. So, der Frederik aus Berlin mit uns am Telefon. Hallo Frederik.
Ich wollte mal fragen, ob ihr mir vielleicht kurz sagen könnt, ob mein Netzwerk zu Hause ein bisschen sicher ist. Und zwar ist...
Gewiss wie ein Finale.
Also ich hab eine Airport-Basistation, also ein wireless LAN-Router und vier Laptops, die... also wir wohnen in einer WG und die surfen halt alle da rüber.
Ist das eine silberne oder eine weiße?
Eine weiße, eine extreme. Und ja, könnt ihr mir dazu irgendwas sagen, ob die okay ist und ob man da irgendwas einstellen muss, dass die vernünftig läuft oder...
Also meines Wissens gibt es da noch keine bekannten Exploits. Ausschließend kann ich das allerdings nicht. Sicherheit ist dann natürlich von beiden Seiten zu betrachten. Das Ding macht halt NAT, wie die meisten. Insofern unterscheidet sich das nicht groß. Genau, DHCP macht das nach innen und... Also NAT natürlich auch nach innen und nach außen. Von daher seid ihr halt so sicher, wie man eben hinter einem NAT sein kann. Eine Firewall Funktionalität gibt es nicht. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt deine Paranoia noch ein bisschen erhöhen willst, brauchst du schon noch etwas Zusätzliches. Das andere Problem, was wir auch schon angesprochen haben, ist grundsätzlich, wenn du WLAN hast, kann dir natürlich auch jemand einfach direkt in dein Funknetz gehen, aus der Nachbarwohnung.
Lokal in der Nähe sein irgendwie, oder?
Ja, naja, das strahlt schon ganz schön weit. Und wenn man da irgendwie eine ordentliche Antenne irgendwo in der Gegend irgendwo hinhält, dann kann das schon reingehen. Also von daher kann man sich nicht sicher sein. Das ist sicherlich kein... Naja, es ist genauso... Also man kann da genauso wenig von sagen, dass es sicher ist. Es gibt halt keinen Zustandsicher. Wie wir das schon mehrfach gebetet haben, ist halt ein Prozess. Bei Mac OS X gibt es vergleichsweise wenig, also eigentlich kaum bekannte Exploits. Es ist natürlich Unix und da sind zahlreiche Tools drauf installiert. Man sollte halt schauen, welche Dienste man eingeschaltet hat. Es gibt da diese Dienste... Genau, diese Sharing Sachen. Schalt halt einfach nur das ein, was du brauchst. FDP würde ich grundsätzlich einfach mal auslassen. Auch das Personal Sharing, Falsharing ist ein bisschen problematisch, weil es halt bei Mac OS X grundsätzlich einen Gastzugang gibt, den man so ohne weiteres nicht ausschalten kann. Das ist ein bisschen bekloppt. Aber was deine Airport Base Station betrifft, solltest du halt zusehen, dass du da auf jeden Fall auch noch mal ein Key drauf hast, also so ein Passwort. Das ist auch noch kein 100%iger Schutz. Und wenn die Liste der Rechner überschaltet, wie schaubar ist die, das benutzen, kannst du auch noch die MAC-Adressen eintragen mit diesem Konfigurationstool.
Ist aber alles letztendlich auch... Also bei WLAN kann man fast abschließend sagen, dass es nichts gibt, was wirklich tatsächlich sicher ist. Also man muss sich schon sehr gut überlegen, ob man irgendwie WLAN haben will, selbst mit 128-Bit-Verschlüsselungen und von mir aus auch noch AES und Pre-Shared Key Authentication und was weiß ich was für ein Schnickschnack. Es ist grundsätzlich immer sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Und man muss sich ja nicht nur überlegen, irgendjemand, der da vorbeikommt, kann jetzt vielleicht mal eine Rechner angreifen, die ich im Netzwerk hab, sondern man muss sich auch überlegen, irgendjemand, der vorbeikommt, kann mal Internetzugang nutzen und kann dann vielleicht von diesem Zugang aus irgendwie einen Angriff machen oder den nächsten Trojaner ins Internet veröffentlichen. Und dann steht irgendwann die Staatsanwaltschaft bei einem vor der Tür, weil das halt über deinen Internetzugang gegangen ist.
Gibt es denn eigentlich trotz allem ein Produkt wie eine Personal Firewall für Mac OS?
Ja, gibt es. Es gibt da...
Das ist doch dann aber echt Bauernfang eigentlich, oder?
Nee, das ist halt genau das gleiche, weil du hast mit der Personal Firewall natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, die Verbindung nach außen interaktiv zu steuern.
Norton hat da eine dabei in seinem Paket auf jeden Fall.
Ja, Norton hat nicht so einen guten Track-Record auf dem Mac, zumindest nicht in letzter Zeit. Ich hab's aber nicht ausprobiert. Es gibt allerdings, was ich sehr mag, der Mac ist eine kleine Company, die heißt IP Softworks. Wie heißen sie denn jetzt? Also IP Netsharing. Oh Gott, jetzt muss ich da nochmal nachdenken. Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr schön.
Diese Brickhouse Firewall?
Ja, die Brickhouse Firewall war eigentlich nur ein Interface, was man bei 10.3 jetzt sowieso drin hat. IP Net. Oh Gott, ich muss mal kurz...
Können wir später ja nochmal...
Ja, ich werf das noch ein. Gibt's was.
Jutti.
Ist die denn tauglich oder...
Ja, das ist halt das normale IPFW von BSD Unix. Und da kann man eigentlich schon sehr filigran, so ähnlich wie bei Linux eben auch, genau einstellen, was eben durchgehen soll oder was nicht. Also wenn dich das interessiert, startest du mal das Terminal und gibst einfach mannipfw ein. Und da findest du eigentlich alle Hinweise darauf, wie man das macht. Und mit dem Kommando ipfw show kannst du dir mal anschauen, was gerade eingestellt ist. Fw für Firewall. Das ist auch ganz interessant, das zu machen, weil die Firewall, die du im GUI hast, die kümmert sich immer, da kann man nur recht grob anklicken, was man eigentlich haben will. Und das macht dann immer TCP und UDP irgendwie gleichzeitig. Also so richtig filigran ist das nicht. Aber das geht dann halt auf der Unix-Ebene so filigran, wie man das haben will. Außerdem gibt es gerade 10.34 Update, da sehe ich gerade sicherlich auch noch mal ein Bug-Fix drin.
Tiger kommt jetzt auch im Sommer.
Genau, eine Punkt-Null-Version hat auf jeden Fall immer ein paar hübsche Bugs.
Okay, schönen Dank erstmal.
Oh, der Norbert ist am Telefon. Hallo, Norbert.
Ja, und zwar für die Windows Benutzer. Hier geht es immer um Linux und so weiter und so fort. Wollt mal eine Lanze brechen für die Windows Freak. Also einführend, ich fahre hier seit 1992, 1993, 94 mit Windows 3.11 von dem Netz gewesen und jetzt Windows XP. Und ich hab eigentlich noch nie irgendwann irgendwelche Würmer, Trojaner, Viren, was weiß ich was auf dem System gehabt.
Hast du denn die Rechner direkt am Netz angeschlossen?
Ja, natürlich.
Also früher Modem, ja. Und jetzt über Satellit.
Hat vielleicht dein Satellitenbetreiber da? Ja Moment, natürlich Satellitenbetreiber. Na klar, die machen auch eh so komisches Internet. Was für ein Anbieter hast du denn da?
Das ist glaube ich ein internes LAN. L-A-N oder wie das nennt man es.
Was ist denn da ein Internet Service Probeider?
Das ist Telekom.
Also normales DSL oder was?
Dieses TDSL über Satellit.
Das ist eigentlich kein Internetzugang, was du da hast. Das hat mit den Protokollen und mit dem, was man im Internet normalerweise spricht, hat das relativ wenig zu tun und kann man daher irgendwie nicht gleichsetzen. Das ist halt doch eine sehr exotische Sache und dadurch gibt es natürlich auch wenige Leute, die sich jetzt mit den Schwachstellen da drin beschäftigen.
Generell ist es so, dass durch diese asynometrische Übertragung, also die Pakete auf dem Hinweg gehen über einen ESDN-Anschluss oder über Telefon und die Pakete zurückkommen über ein Satellit, über die Schnelleleitung. Dadurch ist erstmal schon ein ziemlich komplexes Routing notwendig. Das bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, das legen wir nur für bestimmte Protokolle an. Du hast da, glaube ich, keinen vollwertigen Internetzugang. Lass mich da gern korrigieren. Aber um diese Beschleunigung zu erreichen, müssen sie eh die Pakete ein bisschen anders schicken. Dadurch ergibt sich, denke ich, automatisch schon so eine Mini-Firewall-Funktionalität.
Aber da war immer noch das gleiche Problem, dass du per Mail einfach Viren empfangen kannst.
Dieses DSL-Modem wirkt ja wohl wie so ein Router nachher, ne?
Du hast nicht wirklich ein DSL-Modem, auch wenn dir das die Telekom Marketing-Abteilung verkaufen will als DSL-Modem. Im Prinzip hat dieses Sky DSL oder DSL-Obersetlet mit DSL absolut null zu tun. Das ist nur, weil irgendwie der Otto Normalverbraucher gelernt hat, DSL ist schnelles Internet. Und billig, deswegen nennt man das so. Hat aber mit DSL, mit der Technologie, einer Digital Subscriber Line gar nichts zu tun. Und ist wie gesagt basiert auf ganz anderen Standards.
Ja, jetzt kurz noch eine Frage. Wie groß ist der Unterschied, was Sicherheit anbetrifft, wenn ich jetzt zum einen als Administrator ins Netz gehe oder zum anderen als Benutzer?
Unter Windows. Du solltest auf jeden Fall, wenn es irgendwie geht, immer nur als Benutzer reingehen. Weil dadurch irgendwelche Programme, die du aussehen ausführst, sei es durch Mail oder Browser, was auch immer, haben einfach nur Benutzerrechte und nicht Administratorrechte. Deswegen kann ich jedem nur raten, wenn es irgendwie geht, möglichst nur als Benutzer zu benutzen.
Das tue ich auch und habe gute Erfahrungen, wie gesagt. Es ist ja auch so, dass dann von außen auf dem Benutzerkonto keine Schreibrechte bestehen. Für jemanden. Aber in Trojaner kann man wohl trotzdem drauf bauen, oder wie ist das?
Also, es ist einfach dokumentiert, dass Windows tausende von Sicherheitslöchern hat, die auch täglich millionenfach ausgenutzt werden. Das ist einfach Fakt. Und dass du jetzt da viel Glück gehabt hast, das freut uns sehr. Aber das ist nicht unbedingt exemplarisch.
Ich hab übrigens bisher auch viel Glück gehabt. Ich klicke aber auch nicht auf jedes Mail-Detachment, was mir kommt.
Ich betreibe eine intensive Systempflege, sprich Ad-Ave und sowas alles.
Okay, das hilft auch.
Dass immer die ganze Maschine sauber gehalten wird und ich gucke auch immer nach wie man daher und so weiter und so fort.
Okay, dann nehmen wir dich einfach mal als das leuchtende Beispiel für den heutigen Abend. Tschüss.
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9.
Wir haben es 0, 32. Mit dem Wetter, die Nacht ist bewölkt. Vereinzelt Schauer, die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 3 Grad morgen. Regen, vereinzelt Gewitter, die Temperaturen erreichen 13 bis 15 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Christoph von Guaita.
Der mit Haftbefehl gesuchte Islamist Metin Kaplan ist nach Angaben der Polizei untergetaucht. Die Polizei wollte ihn in Abschiebehaft nehmen. Kurz zuvor hatte das Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster entschieden, dass es keine Hinterungsgründe für eine Ausweisung Kaplans in die Türkei gebe. Der irakische, schiitische Geistliche El Sadre soll den Abzug seiner Kämpfer aus der Heiligen Stadt Najaf angeboten haben. Im Gegenzug müssten die Besatzertruppen die Stadt ebenfalls verlassen. Najaf ist seit April Schauplatz heftiger Kämpfe. Bei den schweren Überschwemmungen in Haiti und der Dominikanischen Republik hat es mindestens 660 Todesopfer gegeben. Mehrere hundert Menschen werden noch vermisst. Die UNO, die Europäische Union sowie nicht Regierungsorganisationen kündigten Hilfe an. Und noch eine Meldung vom Sport. Der FC Porto hat das UEFA Champions League Finale gewonnen. Der portugiesische Meister besiegte in der Arena auf Schalke den AS Monaco mit 3 zu 0. Für Porto ist es der größte Erfolg in der Vereinsgeschichte. Und der Verkehr auf Ritz. A10 östlicher Berliner Ring, Schwanenberg Richtung Spreeau. Zwischen Freienbrink und Spreeau gibt es Behinderungen durch ein defektes Fahrzeug, der rechte Fahrstreifen ist blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin, die B1 Mühlendamm-Gruner-Straße ist zwischen Kreuzung Strahlauer Straße und Kreuzung Karl-Marx-Allee gesperrt. Dort finden Instandhaltungsarbeiten statt, und das noch bis 4 Uhr. Ansonsten, wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Achtung! Sonntag ist kein FM-Tag, weil hoher Besuch. Olli Schulz und sein Hund Marie und die Band Marr bei uns hintereinander, weil gleichzeitig klingt ja ungeil. Und noch was, KenFM bleibt in Berlin und in Bewegung. Sonntag findest du uns in... zu lesen auch unter KenFM.de. Außerdem gibt's natürlich wieder 25 Freikarten für das Berlinowa Festival im Juni. Mann, du willst es doch auch.
KenFM, die Fritz-Radioshow mit Ken Jepsen. Jeden Sonntag von 14 bis 18 Uhr. Ja, ich hab verstanden.
Und im Radio fritz.
Ich hab übrigens rausgefunden, wie das Tool heißt für den Mac. Das möchte ich durchaus noch erwähnen.
Ich habe überhaupt noch nicht gesagt, wie diese Sendung heißt. Bevor ich das noch nicht gesagt habe, hat Keule hier die Muppe zu halten. Das ist nämlich das Chaos Radio. Da geht alles chaotisch zu. Deswegen sagt der Tim manchmal einfach so irgendwas. Nur wieder Harald. Oder der Frank. Mein Name ist der Max. Tim, was wolltest du gerade?
Ich wollte nochmal was für die für die Macintosh Community fallen lassen, was ganz praktisch ist, um sich also was so in den Bereich Personal Firewall reingeht. Gibt es eine kleine Firma, die heißt Sustainable Softworks. sustworks.com. Das war das, das war das, woran du vorhin genau das war, das, woran ich vorhin gegraben habe in meinem Hirn, also es nicht fand. Aber das Internet hat mir Antworten gegeben. Die haben das. Die gibt es schon sehr lange. Also die ist eigentlich ein einziger Programmierer. Das ist so diese typische One Man Show, die in der Macintosh Szene sehr verbreitet ist. Man kennen das auch, so Net News Fire und solche Beispiele. Und der Kerl macht das auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. Er hat ein paar ganz nette Tools. IPnet Monitor ist so ein Analysetool. Und IPnet Sentry ist halt so das, was so in Richtung Personal Firewall geht. Da kann man eine ganze Menge einstellen. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die sind frei. Ein paar kosten ein paar Dollar. Aber wer da jetzt wirklich mal auf Nummer sicher gehen will, ist mit dem auf jeden Fall sehr gut bedient.
Uti, 033-170-97-110 ist unsere Nummer, wenn ihr anrufen möchte beim Chaosradio. Und der Matthias ist dran. Hallo Matthias. Du hast eine Frage.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe interessiert, eure Sendung verfolgt als Blutjunge oder Blutalter Anfänger. Und ganz einfach ausgedrückt, ich habe seit einem halben Jahr erst mal einen PC und demzufolge auch mein und wir im Internet.
Brauche ich einen Router oder brauche ich keinen?
Wie gehst du denn ins Internet? Über Modem oder?
Die Antwort ist nein. Du brauchst keinen.
Du benutzt Windows XP oder?
Nein, Windows 98.
Windows 98.
Also, das hat jetzt mit Router oder nicht so oder nichts zu tun, aber für Windows 98 gibt es meines Wissens nach keine Security-Updates mehr, weil der Support irgendwie ausgelaufen ist von Microsoft.
Dafür sind auch nicht so viele Ports offen.
Also, ja, ist jetzt die Frage, aber Router sind wohl kaum empfehlenswert. Also die Grund- immer, Router brauchst du ja hauptsächlich aus dem Grund heraus, wenn du mehrere Rechner daheim hast, die du mit dem Netz verbinden möchtest gleichzeitig und das hast du ja nicht.
Also, dann ist vielleicht so eine Personal Firewall, auch wenn wir jetzt irgendwie dafür schlagen werden, sowas zu empfehlen, doch wir machen es einfach mal. Also, schauen wir mal, was es da irgendwie an Sachen gibt. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Menge kostenlose Programme. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass sie jetzt unbedingt toll und sicher sind, aber auf jeden Fall kannst du mal schauen, dass du einfach mal ein, zwei, drei Stück davon ausprobierst, verschiedene und dann für dich entscheidest, wo du zum einen das beste Gefühl hast und wo auch irgendwie in der Presse, in einschlägigen Presse auf irgendwelchen Webseiten oder Boards jetzt erstmal nichts Negatives aufgefallen ist. www.heise.de kann ich sehr empfehlen. Heise? Heise, H-E-I-S-E, Heise. Das ist der Verlag von der ziemlich wichtigen Computerzeitschrift CT. Und die haben da so einen News-Ticker, dann kannst du ja auch noch News suchen, da gibts einfach mal irgendwie den Begriff von deinem Produkt ein und dann siehst du schon, ob es da irgendwie was gab.
Die haben auch Infoseiten, ne?
Wenn du da auf die Zeitschrift klickst, also bei CT, bei der Zeitschrift von Heise, es gibt heise.ct und da gibt es unter anderem Share und Freeware und die geben natürlich auch Empfehlungen ab, was man sich draufpacken sollte. Ist vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher.
Also bei der CT, da sitzen auch eine ganze Menge Hacker.
Also das kann man auf jeden Fall uneingeschränkt empfehlen.
Alte Schule ist das.
Genau, wie heißt sie? DE slash Security.
Der Joe aus München.
Hi, grüß dich. Ich ruf an und zwar bezüglich dieses tollen Geekthemas, Router oder Router. Mir geht die Diskussion nicht mehr auf den Keks. Ich kenne die schon seit Jahren.
Dann leistet doch keinen Beitrag zu ihr.
Ja, mein Beitrag ist der. Frag einmal einen Briten, der wird sagen, This is a Router und ein Ami wird sagen, This is a Router. Das ist ganz einfach.
Regional gefärbt. Ja, genau so steht es auch in der Wikipedia.
Also es gibt da gar kein richtig und kein falsch. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum es unterschiedliche Aussagen dazu gibt. Aber es ist einfach eine regionale Abhängigkeit, die hier herrscht.
Also mir hat hier einer im Chat gerade gesagt, Wer Router sagt, frisst auch keine Kinder.
Ja, Router Amis kleine Kinder frissen, das haben wir dahingestellt.
Ja genau, aber das hab ich nicht gesagt.
Ok, und mein zweites Thema, das war Wireless-Lan. Wie mach ich das Ding wirklich sicher?
War nicht.
Doch, und zwar spare ich mir erstmal sämtliche Verschlüsselungen und MAC-Adressfilters und sonst was alles. Und ja, hänge ich einfach in das Wireless-Lan rein. Am besten habe ich noch eine DMZ, eine demilitarisierte Zone im Einsatz. Und dann baue ich einfach einen VPN über die Wireless-Verbindung auf.
Also das kann ich grundsätzlich auch jedem raten, der zu Hause oder auch in einer Firma so ein WLAN-Netz haben will, betrachtet dieses Netz einfach als externes Netz. Also tut so, als wären alle Rechnungen, die da irgendwie über WLAN kommen, irgendwie draußen aus dem Internet kommen.
Ja, und dann eben VPN, wobei VPN hatten wir ja schon, ist ein wahr gedefinierter Begriff. Man sollte zu IPSEC greifen, sofern das möglich ist. Das ist einfach ein Standard und auch mit den entsprechenden Ciphers, wenn man sie einstellt, ein sicheres Protokoll.
Klar, VPN an sich ist erstmal keine Verschlüsselung, keine Sicherheit, sondern ist nur eine virtuelle Vernetzung von entfernten Netzwerken.
Richtig, also ich kann PPTP zum Beispiel betreiben, ohne dass jegliche Verschlüsselung stattfindet. Und selbst wenn ich bei PPTP Verschlüsselung einschalte, dann ist das also so ein ganz obskures Microsoft Zeug, wo es also auch schon Kryptoanalysen dazu gegeben hat. Und das ist nun, naja, also die Sicherheit ist da mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Aber jetzt zieh doch mal nicht so über Microsoft her.
Ich find das ein bisschen fies.
Warum denn? Na ich kann den Gegenzug auch über zum Beispiel CYPE herziehen. Also gegen CYPE, das ist ein unter Linux verbreitetes V4N-Protokoll, da gab es auch eine Kryptoanalyse und die ist auch sehr negativ ausgefallen. Deswegen plädiere ich ja für IPSEC in dem Fall.
Auch VTUN hat am Anfang wohl ein paar Probleme, was die Schlüsselerzeugung angeht.
Ja, auch Replay-Attacken sind gegen viele, also gegen VTUN und CYPE gibt es also Replay-Attacken. Aber PPTP war eben, es ist gut dokumentiert, kam riesig in der Presse raus, gibt es tolle Artikel darüber, was denn da irgendwie das Problem gewesen ist oder auch nach wie vor ist.
Was natürlich auch noch in den Bereich Sicherheit reinfällt, wenn du deinen W-Line jetzt einfach aufmachst, ohne Verschlüsselung, kann sich natürlich jetzt auch jeder erstmal auf deinem Router einbuchen und dann ist es natürlich auch sehr viel einfacher, DOS-Attacken zu fahren, also sozusagen direkt in dein Netz reinzugehen und deine Rechner irgendwie zu überschwemmen, viele Pakete zu verschicken und dann ist es halt auch nicht schön.
Also von daher......deine Netzbandbreite abzuziehen oder eben wie gesagt deinen Internetanschluss zu missbrauchen für irgendwelche Dinge im Netz, sei es irgendwie Verbreitung von Raubkopien, sei es irgendwelche Verbreitung von Trojanen, Würmern, Viren. Und das ist dann letztendlich dein Problem, weil du derjenige bist, der dieses offene Netz betrieben hat.
Aber selbstverständlich, genau dafür habe ich ja meine DMZ im Einsatz. Er wird genau bis zu meinem Router kommen.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, wenn du halt gut Bescheid weißt, dann bist du natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal auf einer sichereren Seite, aber dann weißt du halt auch, dass das alles immer nicht so einfach zu beantworten ist. Zumal jetzt die neueren WLAN-Produkte ja auch eine aktualisierte Verschlüsselung haben. Die ist jetzt noch gleich WPA. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es da schon Bruttoanalyse?
Na, WPA ist ja selber keine Verschlüsselung, sondern das ist ein ganzes Framework. Das ist das 802.1f, glaube ich, gewesen.
Ist klar.
Das ist eine Extra-Sendung.
Genau, da kann man eine ganze Sendung drüber machen. Das ist ein, wie soll ich sagen, ein Konglomerat von 1000 Standards und Protokollen. Zusammen so etwas wie Sicherheit herstellen sollen, ist auch alles sehr vielversprechend, aber neu und keiner implementiert es so richtig vollständig und die Interoperabilität zwischen unterschiedlichen Herstellungen ist noch nicht so toll und so weiter und so weiter.
Also grundsätzlich gilt auf jeden Fall für alle wireless LANs. Bei eurer Basisstation seht zu, dass die Netzwerkei, die nicht ge-broadcasted wird, schaltet die Webverschlüsselung ein und sicherheitshalber auch noch irgendwie die MAC-Adressen, also dass nur bestimmte MAC-Adressen sich einbuchen können, dann macht da auf jeden Fall den War-Drivern oder Leuten, die irgendwie draußen mit dem Laptop vorbeigehen, das Spiel ein bisschen schwerer. Naja, es ist so ein bisschen wie mit den Fahrrädern, die irgendwo angeschlossen sind. Die einen haben halt irgendwie ein ziemlich billiges, ziemlich einfaches Schloss und die anderen haben halt irgendwie ein ziemlich teures, ziemlich starkes, massives Schloss. Und wenn jetzt der Deepin geht, die Fahrräder sind alle gleichwertig, dann wird er natürlich zuerst das nehmen, was irgendwie jetzt das schwache Schloss hat. Damit verlagert ihr das Problem nur, aber ihr seid dann konkret nicht betroffen, wenn ihr im Gegensatz zu den drei anderen Nachbarn, die auch ihre Waveline jetzt so offen haben, wenn ihr dann eine Verschlüsselung habt, das Netz versteckt habt, dann seid ihr mit Sicherheit nicht die ersten.
Das ist das gleiche Prinzip, ob ich jetzt Linux oder Windows einsetze. Wenn ich Linux einsetze, davon gibt es noch nicht ganz so viele wie Windows, ist die kritische Masse nicht da und der Angriff ist etwas schwieriger aufgrund von Security by Obscurity, wie man so schön sagt.
Na, das ist so generell nicht zu sagen.
Generell nicht, nein, aber tendenziell, was die kritische Masse betrifft.
Das ist ein Punkt, es ist schon auch so, aber ich will wirklich nicht in diese leidige Diskussion, die ist auch nicht Thema des Abends, aber es ist schon tatsächlich so, dass man eben in der freien Software Szene, und das hat mit Linux jetzt mal gar nicht ganz konkret nichts zu tun, vor allem irgendwo so implementiert, wie man es technologisch und eben auch unter Sicherheitsaspekten für sinnvoll hält und nicht irgendwelche tollen, bunten Features implementiert und sich über die Sicherheit sehr wenig Gedanken macht.
Oder die Sales-Abteilung dränge, dass die Release endlich fertig werden muss.
Genau, richtig.
Hast du zufällig gerade nochmal die Faustregel bei Hand? Wie lange muss ein Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus offengelegt sein, bis er als sicher gilt?
Da gibt es doch nicht so lange, bis er widerlegt ist.
Also ich meine, über Algorithmen zu diskutieren, ist denke ich irgendwie relativ...
Ganz kurz, Jungs, wir haben nur noch 12 Minuten Zeit, noch ein paar Anrufer, bevor wir jetzt ja ins Klön geraten. Joe, das war es doch, Kronentorhub, ne? Alles klar, mach's gut. Eine Frage, die man sich öfter mal stellt, kommt von Jan aus Berlin.
Ja, schönen guten Abend.
Ich hab einfach die Frage, ich hab ein ganz einfaches Northern Personal Firewall, haben vielleicht mehrere das Programm. Da ist noch die Möglichkeit, unter erweiterten Einstellungen Schutz für UDP zu aktivieren.
Soll ich das machen oder nicht?
Ja.
Generell ja.
Gut, das war's schon.
Du könntest es auch nochmal kurz erläutern. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das so am Anfang erklärt haben. Man spricht ja immer von TCP-IP. Tatsächlich gibt es zwei Protokolle, die im Wesentlichen über IP benutzt werden, nämlich TCP und UDP. Die unterscheiden sich insofern, als dass TCP eben für dauerhafte Verbindungen, wie man sie zum Beispiel beim Webklicken benutzt, verwendet werden und UDP kommt zum Beispiel bei Spielen und bei der Telefonie über das Internet zum Einsatz. Aber es ist letztlich genau so ein Problem wie TCP auch. Von daher grundsätzlich ja.
Danke.
Der Max war gerade pinkeln.
Bevor uns einer Vorwürfe, wir hätten jetzt nicht alles erwähnt. Natürlich die Sache mit den Proxys, das ist ja auch ein sehr populäres Wort. Da hat man jetzt noch nichts zu gesagt.
Vielleicht sollten wir vorher noch, weil es ja auch noch Leuten auf dem Herzen liegt, nochmal diese Geschichte erwähnen, wenn Leute Personal Firewalls haben und so eine Funktion aktiviert haben, dass sämtliche Angriffe, sämtliche Verbindungsversuche von außen protokolliert werden, poppen Fenster auf. Und wir kriegen pro Monat auch etliche Mails. Als TSC wurden Leute sagen, Hilfe! Auf meiner Personal Firewall, da ist jetzt ein Warnfenster aufgegangen und ich bin versucht worden zu hacken. Und dann fragen wir nochmal nach, was ist denn? Ja, da war dann irgendwie ein ICMP Request von irgendeiner IP-Adresse. Da müssen wir den Leuten erstmal sagen, naja, das ist halt ein Ping. Also da hat jemand nur geguckt, ob es den Rechner gibt. Das ist was ganz Harmloses. Und da müssen die Leute natürlich da draußen auch lernen, dann so ein bisschen zu unterscheiden, was sind jetzt wirklich gefährliche Angriffe, also was ist ein ernsthafter Versuch, oder was ist einfach nur so ein routinemäßiges Anklopfen an Türen, ob irgendjemand da ist.
Entschuldige mal, wenn jemand routinemäßig einfach mal an meine Tür klopft, dann gibt es Ärger. Also wieso soll ich...
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Schornsteinfeger.
Nein, ich meine, das beantwortet jetzt die Frage, wieso gibt es da irgendeinen Test, ob mein Rechner nun wirklich da ist oder nicht? Wieso?
Wieso? Na, weil er, keine Ahnung...
Weil er Teil des Internets ist.
Weil jemand mit dir kommunizieren möchte und irgendwie guckt, ob du tatsächlich da bist.
Das muss ja nicht gleich was Böses sein.
Vor allem auch wenn du dynamische IP-Adressen hast, wenn du dich irgendwo einwählst per DSL, dann kann ja unter der gleichen IP-Adresse gestern ein anderer Rechner da gewesen sein. Oder auch noch vor 10 Minuten. Wenn der jetzt irgendeinen Service offen hatte und jemand versucht noch mal da ranzugehen, sei es jetzt ein Web-Server oder ein File-Sharing-Dienst, dann ist natürlich aber dann dein Rechner unter der IP-Adresse und entsprechend gibt es bei dir so eine Warnmeldung. Du weißt gar nicht warum und vielleicht wollte jemand gar nichts Böses von dir. Insofern relaxen. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein gutes Zeichen, dass diese Personal Firewall so eine Sache erkannt hat. Keine Gedanken machen, alles wird gut.
Ping ist halt generell der einfachste Test, den man im Internet überhaupt machen kann. Technisch steckt da ICMP dahinter. Das ist so eine Variante von dem IP. Das ist was vollkommen Normales. Da muss man keine Angst vor haben.
Vielleicht sollte man an der Stelle auch nochmal ansprechen. Ich glaube der Fehler Nummer 1 bei der Konfiguration von Firewalls ist, dass Leute ICMP pauschal sperren. Also das ist dieses Protokoll ICMP Internet Control Message Protocol. Das ist wie TCP und UDP, wie Tim gerade erklärt hat, eben eines dieser Protokolle, die auf IP verwendet werden. ICMP dient einer Reihe von Dingen, die notwendig sind, dass das Netz überhaupt funktioniert. Das geht also nicht nur um diese Ping Anfragen, sondern es geht um zum Beispiel das sogenannte Path MTU Discovery, das ich nicht erklären werde. Das führt zu weit, solange es die Sendung nicht mehr. Aber es sind einfach Funktionalitäten, die notwendig sind, damit das Netz sauber funktioniert. Dann gibt es halt so eine ganze Reihe von Pseudo-Administratoren mit Pseudo-Wissen, die also sagen, oh ICMP ist böse, das wird gesperrt und dann funktioniert das Netz halt nicht mehr so wie es sein soll.
Genau, man muss halt immer wissen, was man tut. Was das jetzt noch mal abrundet, wir müssen das erwähnen mit der Firewall-Geschichte. Also lange bevor solche Sachen wie Masker-Rating und die weiterentwickelten Firewall-Systeme überhaupt auf den Markt kamen, waren halt Proxys so immer das, was man als erstes für eine Firewall hielt oder auch das gehört sozusagen dazu. Das bezieht sich, wenn man von einem Proxy spricht, meint man in der Regel ein Webproxy. Das ist einfach ein Programm, was sich zwischen meinem Webbrowser und allen Web-Servern, die ich anklicke, dazwischen hängt.
Webbrowser ist ein sehr populäres Programm.
Ja gut, das sind jetzt die, die erstmal rausfiltern. Also ein Proxy generell ist erstmal an sich keine schlechte Idee. Der versucht halt den Traffic nach draußen. Damals musste man noch viel dafür bezahlen. Bei Flatrates ist das nicht mehr so ein Thema. Zwischenzuspeichern, wenn eine Seite schon mal abgerufen wurde vom internen Netz, dann liefert das halt der Proxy.
Proxy Cache, genau.
Cache, genau.
Und ist damit eigentlich auch vergleichbar mit der Cache-Funktion im Browser. Da könnt ihr euch mal durch die Optionen durchklicken oder mal googlen, was es ist. Genau, nichts anderes macht auch dieser externe...
Aber Proxy kann auch ein richtiger Schmerz im Hintern sein. Vor allem so bei Firmen, die es irgendwie gar nicht so begreifen und der Meinung sind, man braucht ja auch nur Web auf diesem Planeten, wenn man da irgendwie so mit so einem halbwegs gut installierten Laptop hinkommt und dann so seine Programme startet und nichts geht erstmal, weil nur das denn zugelassen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob es gibt so Orte. Und nicht selten ist dann eben auch zusätzlich nicht nur alle Ports gesperrt, sondern dann auch noch ein Proxy. Ein Proxy kann, naja, kann eine Hilfe sein, aber meistens macht er eher ein bisschen Ärger, weil man eben nicht zuverlässig sagen kann, dass irgendwie eine Seite auf dem Server sich jetzt doch wirklich geändert hat und man möchte jetzt bitte mal die aktuelle Version haben und der liefert einem immer nur die Kopie. Das ist so ein bisschen doof.
Aber es ist nicht auch so, dass im Endeffekt, zum Beispiel wenn ich mich jetzt über die Uni einlogge, als mein Provider, dass da auch erstmal so eine Art Proxy steht, auf dem dann die Webseite abgerufen wird.
Das hängt mal ganz von deiner Uni ab. Also wenn du zu mir in die Uni kommst, da gibt es richtiges Internet.
Also das ist eben auch vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal zu erwähnen bei diesen Proxys, ja. Das hat dann, also ein Netzwerkzugang hinter einem Proxy ist nicht mit einem Internetzugang zu verwechseln. Das hat mit dem Internet eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu tun. Nur weil ich ein paar Webseiten sehe, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass ich mit dem Internet verbunden bin. Ja, die, wenn ich einen Proxy irgendwo habe in einer, bei einem Internet oder was auch immer Zugang, bei einem Webzugang sagen wir mal, dann wird diese eine Verbindung, die ich normalerweise habe, zwischen dem Client, also dem Browser und dem Server, in diesem Fall der Web Server, wird aufgespalten in zwei Verbindungen. Ich habe eigentlich nur von meinem PC aus, von dem Browser, eine Verbindung zum Proxy und der Proxy macht dann selber eine Verbindung auf zum Server. Im Grunde ist also hier eine ganz stricte Trennung auf einer ganz anderen Ebene vollzogen und demnach ist das aus Sicht eines Netzwerkers kein Internetzugang.
Ganz kurz, wir haben noch 5 Minuten Zeit bis zum Ende der Sendung. Der Sebastian aus Coburg, hallo Sebastian. Ist schon futschi, sorry. Und der Manuel aus Henningsdorf noch.
Ja, folgendes Problem.
Ich hatte kürzlich folgenden Vorfall, dass über meinem Router wirklich bloß Port 80 freigegeben war.
Und ich das Problem hatte, dass ich über dem Port 80 tatsächlich Quellcode über meinem Browser auf meinem Rechner installiert habe, der ernsthaft versucht hat, eine DFU-Verbindung einzurichten. Lässt sich sowas unter Umständen vermeiden oder fällt ein Nein?
Das war dann bestimmt so ein ActiveX-Control oder sowas?
Das ist gut möglich, ja.
Ja, doch, das könnte den kommen.
Dann können wir dir einfach mal Mozilla als Browser empfehlen, anstelle des Internet-Explorers.
Ja, so obskure Sachen wie Java und ActiveX, das sollte man auf seinem Browser ausschalten.
Ja, manchmal braucht man es ja leider doch, genauso wie mit Windows, eigentlich will man es nicht, und trotzdem kommt man nicht.
Da kann man für bestimmte Seiten immer noch den Internet-Explorer benutzen.
Ja gut, das...
Die hin reicht vertrauenswürdig.
Also mein Computer kennt überhaupt gar keinen ActiveX und ich vermisse nichts.
Echt jetzt, ja?
Ich hab's eine Zeit lang mal deaktiviert und hab dann festgestellt, na gut, einiges funktioniert doch nicht.
Ja, aber das kommt an Early-Jubel-Jahre mal vor.
Ja, aber das sind auch Dinge, die will man gar nicht, dass die funktionieren auf dem Computer.
Richtig, ist halt die Frage, was ich will. Brauche ich irgendwelche obskure Funktionalität, die von irgendwelchen Website-Betreibern angeboten wird in ActiveX oder will ich irgendwie im Einsatz einer Sicherhaben? Das sind halt irgendwie zwei Fragen, die ich mir erstellen muss und dann muss ich mich halt irgendwie für eine Seite entscheiden.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Gute Nacht, tschüss.
Ich will nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir auf www.ccc.de einen Hinweis darauf haben, wie man sein Windows zumindest ein kleines bisschen sicherer machen kann, indem man nämlich alle nicht benötigten Dienste abschaltet, damit dann auch weniger Ports oder möglichst gar keine Ports von außen offen sind. Da gibt es auch eine kleine Erklärung dazu, was das alles mit dem Sasserwurm zu tun hat und wie wir dazu stehen. www.ccc.de und dann im Moment gleich die oberste Meldung Hacker stopfen Windows Sicherheitslöcher oder so ähnlich.
Und ich will noch mal auf die Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia hinweisen. Den Link findet ihr auf www.chaosradio.com.ch auf dem Artikel zu dieser Sendung. Dort könnt ihr auch Tipps, wenn ihr welche habt, Anmerkungen, ULZ und so weiter dort einfach noch mit eintragen. Dann ist das ein schönes Dokument für alle, die jetzt noch mal nachlesen wollen, worum das hier eigentlich alles ging. Und natürlich haben wir das ein oder andere nicht beantworten können, weil die Zeit einfach knapp ist. Aber ich möchte mich noch mal bedanken hier insbesondere bei dem vollständig überlaufenden Chaosradio Chat. Da hatten wir Zeit, weilig 120 Leute drin. Die haben sich hier alle sehr bemüht und ich denke, die werden auch noch ein bisschen drin rumbleiben, rumhängen in dem Chat. Vielleicht auch nicht. Aber wenn ihr noch eine Frage habt, dann könnt ihr einfach mal dorthin marschieren auf irc.freenote.net in den Chaosradio-Kanal. Ja, und...
Wir sollten vielleicht noch ganz kurz auf die VOSS hinweisen. 10.
bis 12. Juni in Berlin gibt es eine Veranstaltung, die heißt Wizards of Oz, die sich mit Open-Source-Technologien auseinandersetzt, vor allem sehr viel auch mit Lizenzen. Dort werden auch ein paar sehr bekannte Sprecher sein. Lorenz Lessig wird dort eine Rede halten, der Gründer der Wikipedia ist vor Ort, und es gibt da sehr interessante Panels. Die Creative Commons-Gruppe Deutschland wird sich dort gründen. Am 11. Juni, am Freitag, gibt es auch eine Wikipedia-Party in der Seabase am Abend. Das ist sicherlich auch sehr interessant, wo die ganze Community zusammenkommt. Also es ist eine Menge los, und wir werden da auch auf unserer Webseite nochmal darüber informieren.
Wobei das Ganze mehr eine theoretische Veranstaltung ist. Da wird nicht so angepackt. Es gibt kein Hackcenter wie auf dem Kongress. Das ist schon eine andere Zielrichtung. Aber wer da Interesse hat an den Hintergründen und auch mal ein bisschen diskutieren will mit anderen Leuten über freie Software, freien Content, der ist da genau richtig aufgehoben.
Softwarepatente.
Ich weiß, Max.
Wir sind ja durch.
Ja, wir sind ja auch durch. Bevor jetzt noch einer so auszudehmen, kann man sich da auch mal am Sack raulen, wenn man da nix zu tun hat. Das waren Frank, Harald, Tim und Max. Chaosradio Ausgabe Nummer 92 zum Thema Firewalls nachzulesen. Habt ihr alles schon gehört? Wir sagen Tschüss, viel Spaß beim Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Machts gut. Tschüss.